. Hallo Wien! Wahnsinn, ist hier voll neue! Hey! Hey Wien! Dankeschön! Wahnsinn! Vielen Dank! Wahnsinn, das ist wirklich cool! Vielen Dank! Dankeschön, schön, dass ihr da seid! Hey! Stefan Tietze, meine Damen und Herren! Und Valentin Vömer, meine Damen und Herren! Wir haben noch nichts gemacht, wir haben noch nichts gemacht! Das ist mega cool, das ist mega cool! Vielen Dank! Hallo! Hallo, freut uns der, wir hatten grosse Angst, dass unser Auftritt nicht gut funktioniert aus dieser sehr engen Treppe, aber ich finde, Stefan hat das sehr, sehr gut gemacht. Ja, es war so dieser Tippellauf, den man kennt, wenn die Treppenstufen ein bisschen zu schmal sind, immer so vorsichtiges... Ich glaube, du könntest die epischste Musik aller Zeiten spielen, wenn du einfach so die Treppe runterläufst, das funktioniert einfach nicht. Rocky war auch ein großes Problem, wir haben erst lange mit so viel zu kurzen Treppen gedreht, aber da war das nicht mehr so episch, da war es eher so... Ey, das war echt zu gefährlich. Bist du ein Geländer-Typ? Ja. Ich gar nicht.
Nee? Du hast lange mit so viel zu kurzen Treppen gedreht, da war das nicht mehr so episch, da war es eher so ein ... Es war echt zu gefährlich. Bist du ein Geländer-Typ? Ja. Ich gar nicht. Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie wirklich so mit einer Hand am Geländer und dann runter. Ach, du meinst beim Treppen gehen. Ich bin generell nicht pro Geländer, wollte ich mal sagen. Ich bin pro Safety, ich bin Safety-Typ. Ich bin pro Helm, pro Geländer, pro Knieschoner. Ja. Das ist mein Ding, auch im echten Leben. Man sollte häufig immer mit Knieschononer rumlaufen. Ich bin gestern hier durch Wien gelaufen abends und da war dann eine Asiatin, spielt gar keine Rolle, das ist eine Asiatin, aber läuft jedenfalls, ja vielleicht ein bisschen, kommen wir gleich drauf, sie kommt jedenfalls, sie läuft vor mir her und ich habe noch jemanden gesehen, der sich so aufs Maul legt, in meinem ganzen Leben, sie ist einfach gelaufen und ich weiß nicht, sind hier die Normen für die Bürgersteige andere als in Asialand? Ich weiss es nicht. Sie ist dann einfach dagegen gelaufen und ist einfach komplett auf die Chance gefahren, also wirklich mit dem Gesicht vorneweg. Und alle sind dann hingegangen und dachten, wie kann das denn passieren? Niemand wusste es einfach. Dann ist sie einfach weiter gelaufen und dann kam Drive Now und dann ist sie da eingestiegen und weggefahren und das war das weirdeste Erlebnis der Welt. So, warum, sie ist keinen Weg gegangen, hat auf irgendeinen gewinne gewartet oder so, sie ist einfach gegangen, ist hingefallen, aufgestanden, weitergegangen und in fremdes Drive Now gestiegen. So als ob sie beim Hinklatschen gemerkt hat, mein Leben ist jetzt vorbei, ich führe jetzt ein anderes Leben. Ich entführe mich jetzt selbst, scheiss drauf, vielleicht warst du eine Art Blind Date und so als Erkennungsmerkmal und du erkennst mich daran, dass ich alle 50 Meter auf die Fresse falle und dann, das ist sie. Du erkennst mich an dem blutigen Gesicht, ich will keinen mit dem blutigen Gesicht mit meinem Drive Now einführen. Aber ich bin überhaupt kein Geländertyp, ich glaube, ich benutze Geländer nie, außer früher als ich Skateboard gefahren bin, als ich noch ein Dark Slide konnte, dann war das natürlich regelmässig. Dark Slide?
Dark Slide, das ist wenn man...
Dark Slide of the room.
Sorry, jetzt muss ich ein bisschen in Skatersprech gehen.
Klar, komm, zeig mir die Tricks.
Wenn du auf deinem Brett, also Skateboard, wenn du auf deinem Brett die Strasse runtergroovst und dann kommt so eine Kick und dann spayst du so hoch und dann drehst du alles auf den Kopf und dann scrollst du so auf, einen schwarzen Teil des Bretts so auf die Geländer runter. Es ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu krass für euch. Ihr seid nicht jung genug, ihr seid nicht alt genug, ihr seid nicht genau richtig alt. Ja und in Wien keine Skateboards, hier sind diese Elektroroller am Start, die aber sau gefährlich. Das ist gefährlich, er hat heute so einen sehr alten Menschen gesehen, der einfach ohne ein Gesicht zu verziehen, no bullshit, 100 kmh mit diesem Elektroroller gefahren ist. Der vor allem eine Taucherbrille aufhatte. Das war nicht sein erster Elektroroller-Rodeo. Der Mann wusste, was er tut. Ich habe auch diesen ernsten Blick, diesen, ich weiß, wenn da jetzt gleich ein Ziegelstein liegt, ich sterbe, ich fliege zehn Meter weit und so auf so einem Haufen Asiaten, die alle über die Bürgersteine gefallen sind, und dann liege ich da einfach. Aber der wusste, man sterbt keinen Helm auf gar nichts, die Taucherbrille hilft ihm jetzt auch nicht, vor dem Tod oder so. Man weiss es nicht genau, vielleicht ist es am Ende das, was den Unterschied macht, die Taucherbrille. Ich weiss es nicht, ich bin selten mit Taucherbrille unterwegs. Taucherbrille war primär mit Wind zu ertragen, so eine Windschutzscheibe, so kleine Scheibenwischer. Gegen die ganzen Fliegen, die da gegen dort sind. Aber ich war gestern unterwegs und die Miniroller sind nicht so cool. Sie sind schon cool, aber ich bin gestern durch die schwarze Nacht gelaufen und dann bin ich auf eine Gang gestossen. Gang. Ausrollern? Es müssen fünf Jugendliche gewesen sein. Ja. Es müssen fünf Jugendliche gewesen sein, die sich alle so einen Roller besorgt haben. Und die so wirklich so einen Kreis gefahren sind. Wirklich so, ey, wun, wun, wun, wun. Die haben so ein dickes Kind aus der Klasse gemobbt und sind mal rumgefahren. Und das dicke Kind so, hey, Leute. Aber es ist halt überhaupt nicht furchteinflössend, weil die sehen halt überhaupt nicht cool aus und ich dachte mir so,
oh endlich mal eine Mobflägerei, jetzt mal so eine Gang so richtig, hä, was willst du denn hier so und dann kann man sich so,
hä, die Luft ist mit Blei gewürzt und so, dann kann man sich diese
coolen Sprüche unterwerfen, bevor man zusammengeschlagen wird.
Die Luft ist mit Blei gewürzt.
Ja, oder was, ich weiß nicht, was ihr jungen Leute heute so sagt, bevor ihr ein Ausländer zusammenschlagen, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, was da gerade so die Trends sind.
Das weiß ich auch nicht.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber ich weiß nicht, vor allem, ich denke mir so, wenn du diese Crew siehst mit den fünf Rollern, die müssen die ja alle von anderen Orten bekommen haben, weil du siehst ja nie fünf Roller gleichzeitig nebenbei, sondern die müssen gesagt haben, so heute... Das ist die Regel, du siehst nie fünf Roller gleichzeitig. Nee, das heißt, die müssen gesagt haben, heute machen wir Gang Action hier an der vierzehnten im hundertsten Distrikt, was auch immer, und dann haben die gesagt, so, okay, ich hole meine Rolle aus dem dritten, du aus dem neunten, ich aus dem achten und dann treffen die sich alle in der Mitte. Also, was ich sagen will, je besser Gangs organisiert sind, desto uncooler sind sie, weil man weiß, da ist ein Doodle dahinter, hinter dieser Gang-Aktion steckt ein Doodle und man hat sich genau... Hinter jeder Versammlung, so furchterregen sie sich auch sein mag, steht ein Google-Doodle. Ja, stimmt, aber es macht es ein bisschen uncooler irgendwie. Wenn ich von Leuten zusammengeschlagen werde, dann halt irgendwie von so Anarchisten, so richtig krassen Typen und nicht dieses geplant haben. Wie organisieren sich Anarchisten? Wer gründet die WhatsApp-Gruppe? Darin scheitert es doch schon. Niemand will sie gründen, weil niemand derjenige sein will, der sie Gruppe anführt. Wahrscheinlich sagen die immer so, wir treffen uns am fünften, aber alle so, du kannst mir gar nichts sagen. Und dann kommen wir, lass uns einfach. Ich kann es alleine mit so ganz vielen Lachs-Schnitten stehen, an so einem Anker-Fee. Ich habe Nudelsalat gemacht, Leute. Ich habe Mettbrötchen überall gemacht und niemand ist gekommen. Das fühlst du, glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, Anarchist sein ist sehr unankbar. Hattest du mal eine Anarchistenphase? Wird mich jetzt wundern, wenn nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Wirklich jetzt? Ja. Ne, ich habe, glaube ich, nie eine Anarchistenphase fand Regeln immer gut. Ja. Dinge, die man hören will an einem Comedy-Abend. Ich fand Regeln immer gut. Wer ist noch für Regeln? Wir sind so eine Schulveranstaltung, wo wir gerade sind. Wer ist noch für Regeln, Leute? Wer ist noch für Regeln? Ja! Okay, okay, okay, die Jugend. Aber ich finde gut, dass das Publikum mit Impro macht, aber die Rolle falsch spielt. So, wir reden gerade um eine Schulveranstaltung, ich bin die Schüler und ihr findet die Regeln gut. Das ist die neue Generation, man hat sie nicht unter Kontrolle. Aber zum Thema, auf die Fresse fallen, ich erinnere mich noch an die Zeit, als man viel mit Schulkindern zu tun hatte. Und es gibt ja nichts Schöneres als ein Schulkind mit einem schweren Rucksack, das vorne überfällt. Einfach wirklich, dieser Rucksack macht einfach noch diesen Ticken Demütigung, den es noch braucht. Einfach vor allem, du weisst auch, das Kind steht so schnell nicht auf, weil das hat erstmal 60 Kilo über dem Kopf und dann riss es so hin und her. Und dann ist meistens der Gän, dass der Rucksack noch auf ist und die ganzen Bücher rausrutschen. Ja, und dann das Sexualkundebuch direkt über den Asphalt geschlittert. Das Tagebuch genau zu Nina. Nina. Die beiden fallen genau übereinander. Oh nein, dann fallen die Nacktbilder von Nina aus der Umkleide raus und man denkt sich, oh, die Story war gerade noch relatable, jetzt ist es nicht mehr. Und man muss seine gesamte Pubertät auf dem Asphalt verbringen mit einem riesigen Scott-Rucksack über seinem Kopf. Du hast auch nicht schön den Asphalt geleckt. Ja, schön, richtig. Ich habe die Kurve gekratzt, ich habe wirklich, bei mir ging es richtig rund. Ich bin richtig auf dem Boden geflogen. Ja, durch dieses Plastikband tatsächlich, das habe ich im Podcast erzählt, dass das Plastikband einfach scheint, dieser Ringplastik, ich bin ja keine Schildkröte. Da gehe ich jetzt nicht drum rum, ich bin bescheuert, ich bin der Mensch. Ja, ich bin so ein scheiß Plastiker und ich bin voll auf die Fresse gefallen, will ich mit ersten Fuß rein zweiter Fuss rein, auf die Fresse direkt. Bist du mich daran, du weisst viel zu früh, dass das gleich schief geht? Ja. Du weisst früh, du kannst dir noch rationale Gedanken machen, warum das gerade blöd aussieht, was dir passiert. Ja, du kannst deine Fehler noch mal genau reflektieren, bevor die Konsequenzen kommt. Ja, genau. Ich hätte es gleich nicht reintreten sollen, bumm, aah. Ja, ja, es ging viel zu schnell. Das ging zu schnell. Hattest du ein Tagebuch? Ähm, ich habe viel angefangen. Ich habe bei mir zuuse liegen viele … Du warst immer unzufrieden. Das war Scheisse, die Story führt zu nichts. Fuck, das ist ein Scheiss, passiert gar nichts, ist langweilig. Kann mich nicht mit dem Charakter identifizieren, weg, hau ab jetzt hier. Ich stehe auf Nina, spoilert direkt die Scheisse! Das ist eine Kacke. Ich habe ganz viel angefangen und die erste Seite ist immer beschrieben. Und man merkt so, die Schrift ist noch sauber, als ich meine Adresse eingetragen habe, so, dann kommt Seite zwei und dann kommt Liebes Tagebuch.
Und dann ist Tagebuch schon so, hat schon so einen Kringel nach unten, weil ich schon da nicht gecheckt habe, wann die Seite vorbei ist.
Und man beginnt so Tagebuch und dann auch, okay.
Ich glaube, ich habe auch mehrfach mit meinem Tagebuch Schluss gemacht, so hey, wir haben uns nichts mehr zu sagen und irgendwie, ich habe das Gefühl, da kommt hauptsächlich was von mir und von dir kommt gar nichts zurück irgendwie, das ist eins, ich sehe keine Zukunft mit dir, mach's gut, ich habe wirklich, mein Tagebuch ist glaube ich recht interessant und das sehr verwirrend zu lesen, weil ich habe massive Zeitsprünge drin, es ist wirklich so fünfte Klasse, fünfte Klasse, fünfte Klasse, fünfte Klasse, fünfte Klasse, zwölfte Klasse. Einfach so ein Sprung, wo du denkst, Moment mal, du hast jetzt gerade Sticker bestellt und freust dich darauf, dass du die... Und dann, Moment mal, du hast deine Lehrerin geküsst, was ist jetzt, was ist das passiert? Und dann kommt der Zeitsprung. Es ist ein bisschen wie so ein Mängelexemplarbuch, wo die Hälfte draußen ist oder so. Es gibt manchmal, dass Bücher falsch gedruckt werden, dass die Kapitel in der falschen Reihenfolge sind, und dann werden die als Mängelexemplare verkauft. Und es muss Menschen geben. Ich denke, das wären diese True-Your-On-Adventure-Bücher, wo man dann ein bisschen ein paar Seiten überspringen muss. So funktionieren Bücher. Nein, die sind einfach... Und es muss Menschen geben, die diese Bücher lesen und sich denken, was zur Hölle ist jetzt los? Erst war er im Gefängnis, dann geht er zur Grundschule, jetzt ist er wieder geboren, was ist los? Eines von diesen postmodernen Romanen, ich verstehe es einfach nicht. Sind Tagebücher postmoderne Romane? Da frage ich Sie jetzt, Herr Kreisler. Ja, es ist natürlich der Exkurs der Langweiligkeit, also des Allgemeinen, des Drögen, aber man weiss immer, wie es endet. Man weiss immer, sehen Sie, das ist ja der moderne Mensch, gefangen in seinem eigenen Kopf, gefangen in seinem eigenen Körper. Der Schlaf ist die einzige Zuflucht, die ihm noch geblieben ist. Ist mal jemand bei einer Live-Sendung eingeschlafen eigentlich? Ich kenne da jemanden, aber das möchte ich jetzt nicht voll... Ja, das war der Vollbandbefehl der Nacht halt. Ja, gut, aber ich meine, das war der Pilot für das Online-Wetten-Das, Stefan. Ja, mein Gott. Wir hatten Guy Ritchie da und Ritchie Guy und alle waren da. Das Lied war so langsam und es ist wie Sleep, Sleep, Baby, Sleep. Das war das Intro, das Intro. Dene, junge Generation. Anne Frank hat auch ein Tagebuch geschrieben. Wäre die zu Wten das gekommen? Was soll sie erraten? Haben die Nazis versucht, sie so aus dem Haus zu locken, so dass sie so ... Nazis unter Geräuschen erkennen. Und heute bei uns zu Gast, Anne Frank! Und sie so, fuck it, komm scheiße auf! Sie muss sich neun von zehn Mal verstecken, dass man sie nicht findet. Das finde ich so schlecht. Das stimmt, ja. Sturmmannführer Dieter Hellström wettet, dass er mit verbundenen Augen... Dieter Hellström aus Bergen wettet, dass er es schaffen kann. Ich glaube, meine einzige Motivation... Ich glaube, alle Fragen... Ich bin noch nicht fertig damit. Ich wollte einfach... Ich weiss nicht, gut. Wie ist das politische Klima gerade hier eigentlich? Ich weiss es nicht, wir haben nur draußen Sticker gesehen, FCK, FPÖ. Sorry, aber findet ihr das nicht selber so ein bisschen lächerlich, das Ö da drin immer? Ö immer drin. Oder, also jetzt nichts gegen Österreich an sich, aber immer dieser Umlaut. Es ist doch ein Scheiß, Umlaut. Es ist Quatsch, ich habe ja teilweise schon Probleme, Dinge nach Köln zu bestellen, weil bei amerikanischen Seiten man oft das Ö nicht eintippen kann. Wie viel ist schon nach Österreich gegangen, einfach irgendwo an die Osterinseln oder so? Die freuen sich da, so ein Ureinwohner stammen, die Menschen essen und geile Pakete bekommen, das ist so deren Dinge. Das ist ein guter Nachmittag einfach, so muss es sein. Ich bin mir auch nicht sicher, wie das ist hier gerade politisch. Ich glaube, es ist angespannt, aber ich meine, solange es diese Sticker gibt, ist alles in Ordnung, glaube ich. Es passt schon. Ich habe mal ein Paket bekommen, das dann beim Zoll gelandet. Das ist mir noch nie passiert. Ich habe mich so illegal, also ich habe mich so illegal bestellt gefühlt. So habe ich mir nur, weil ich noch nie beim Zoll war und ich dachte mir, da kam mir so ein Brief vom Zoll und da denkt man so, oh, okay.
Das fand ich so ein bisschen cool auch.
Und dann bin ich da hingefahren und man merkt, da sitzt man in so einem Warteraum wie beim Arzt und man merkt, dass alle sich so ein bisschen schämen dafür, gerade was bestellt zu haben, was nicht so hundertprozentig wasserdicht ist.
Aber alle fühlen sich auch so ein bisschen cool, so ein bisschen, sie wollen auch, dass ausgerufen wird.
Ich fühle mich ein bisschen kriminell.
Herr Schmidt wegen ihrem Katana, naja, ich mal wieder. Katana ist ein japanisches Schwert für alle nicht-jungen Frauen hier im Raum. Da kann ich dich beruhigen, die Dichte ist relativ gross. So, ja, und dann kam halt so ein Typ, der dann alle unsere Zettel eingesammelt hat, und dann ist er gegangen und dann kam er mit so einem Wagen wieder, wo man dann schon die verschiedenen Formen der Pakete sah.
Einfach 80% Dildos einfach.
Ja, so komische Formen, so längliche Formen und alle so, oh Gott, hoffentlich.
Aber hier halt schon so zusortiert, wem wohl was gehört.
Ja, wie in so einem Spiel für so Fünfjährige, wo man immer sagt, wem gehört der Hase? Ja, genau, wem gehört der Hase. Und was hattest du dann am Ende? Was hast du bekommen? In der grossen Phallus-Tombola, hast du den Hauptpreis gewonnen, Stefan? Dildo. Ja, auch ein Dildo? Schwierig. Man hat ja so nach dem Studium oder generell nach der Schule oft so diese Phase, so was soll ich machen, was soll ich werden als Beruf und so. Und dann hat mich so ein Kumpel gefragt, so du, ich habe echt gar keine Ahnung, was ich machen soll. Dann hast du gesagt, warte einfach, bis Frank Elstler dich anruft, dann Jan Wimmermann dich anruft, du dann einfach in Sendungen kommst, immer wiederkommen sollst, obwohl du keinen Bock darauf hast und gar nicht irgendwie den Drive hast, eigene Beiträge zu kreieren. Nein, warte einfach drauf, bis andere Leute die andauernd Dinge schenken. Nicht ganz, nicht ganz. Nicht ganz, er hat tatsächlich so was, er hat gesagt so was wie, sag jetzt einfach mal irgendwas und das mache ich einfach, weil ich habe keinen Bock, mir den ganzen Tag zu Hause rumzusitzen, ich will jetzt einfach mal was machen, mir ist eigentlich egal was, ich will einfach nur aktiv werden im Leben, ich will einfach irgendeinen Job anfangen. Und da habe ich gesagt, ja pass auf, geh doch zum Zoll.
Das ist mir in dem Moment eingefallen, weil ich dachte mir, ist ein geiler Job, du hast mit Schlangen zu tun. Und es sagt sich geil, Zoll. Du hast mit exotischen Tieren zu tun, niemand stellt Fragen, wenn er sagt, ich arbeite immer im Zoll, alle so, Zoll. Ja, Masseinheit und Grenzkontrolle, das ist ein guter Job.
Und tatsächlich hat er für einen kurzen Moment so gedacht so, hm. Aber dann dachte er sich, jetzt will ich mein ganzes Leben darauf baue, was Florentin Wilm hier im Alter von 16 gesagt hat, ist schon ein bisschen komisch. Er ist dann nicht zum Zoll gegangen. Jetzt ist ein Nazi tatsächlich bei der way ganz anderen Wege gegangen. Vielleicht wäre es besser gewesen, wenn er zum Zoll gegangen wäre. Weiss ich nicht, aber das ist so ein bisschen auch schwierig. Oder sein, wenn dann die ganzen Mein Kampf rausgefiltert werden und dann liegen die alle bei ihm zu Hause rum und dann ist es halt mal langweilig und dann liest man. Aber Zoll ist ein geiler Job, du hast mit exotischen Tieren zu tun, da wäre dann ja so ein Gepard irgendwie so, wenn die dann in den Gepard schmuggeln. Das wäre ganz lustig, wenn er mit diesem Wagen wiederkommt und da hängen nur drei Geparden, folgen ihm einfach, auch so gelangweilt. Mit so einem ertappten Blick so, ja, was soll. Aber es ist doch einfach so ein Praktik, der die gelangweilt, als wäre es das Normalste in der Welt, schiebt die so hinterher, komm hier so ein Krokodil. Und die Eltern müssen die so aus der Schule abziehen, so was hast du diesmal falsch gemacht, du hast mit Drogen zu tun, du hast mit Waffen zu tun, aber das ist völlig legal, das ist doch mega geil.
Oder nicht?
Habt ihr keinen Bock auf den Zoll?
Ich weiß nicht genau.
Dieser Abend wird übrigens gesponsert vom Zoll, deutschem Zoll.
Und von Heckler und Koch.
Und von Panther. Die brauchen dringend Leute beim Zoll, glaube ich, oder?
Ich weiß nicht genau, braucht man Leute beim Zoll? Ist mittlerweile in Europa auch gar nicht mehr so ein grosses Ding, oder?
Keine Ahnung, du kriegst ja dann so ein Paket und schüttelst dann mal so, riechst dann mal so dran und dann trittst du so dagegen und sagst, passt, nächstes. Und dann so machst du es den ganzen Tag so, mega geil. Ist es nicht einfach nur, ich hab keine Ahnung, aber du hast einfach die Mehrwertsteuer drauf, oder? Das ist doch das, was halt meistens passiert. Nee, das ist schon eine Aufregung. Ist das nicht meistens, die haben einen Taschenrechner da gehabt, wo ich mir auch dachte, ihr braucht nur die Plus-19-Prozent-Taste, ihr braucht nicht. Ja, das stimmt. So funktioniert Zoll, viel Raum. Ich glaube, die müssen halt alles rausziehen, was gefährlich ist. Und dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, dann machst du so eine Kiste auf, dann sind da dann Skorpione drin. Und dann haben die bestimmt so einen Ausruf, so ein B36. Ja, oder vielleicht egal ganze Zoll auf oder so und dann alle so, ahu und dann die ganze Zollstelle hat Bock oder so. Ich glaube, die haben da einfach einen Riesenspass. Ich habe aber auch keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist es mega spannend. Die haben keine Ahnung von Zoll. Wir wissen wirklich fast nichts von dieser Welt. Ich glaube, die Leute lachen so wenig, weil es etwas hier gar nicht gibt, Zoll. Ich weiß auch nicht. Ja, hast du schon mal jemanden Zollmeister gesehen, gesehen, also einen Zollkollegen? Ich weiss gar nicht, wie die hat, Zöllner? Die Zöllnerdichte war da relativ gross beim Zoll, tatsächlich. Ja, so. Als ich dann da war. Aber sind ja nicht immer so undercover, dass sie so im Flugzeug mitfliegen und dann sagen so, das ist kein G-Stock. Ich bin Zöllner. Das ist kein G-Stock, das ist eine AK-47, sehe ich doch. Und dann der alte Herr so, verdammt, dann reißt er sich den Bart ab. Aber auch niemanden warnt, sondern einfach in den letzten drei sitzt. Das seh ich doch, aber auch keine Angst hat oder so. Ja, dann reißt er sich den Bart ab, unterm Hut so lauter illegale Bienen, und dann und dann Freeze-Frame und dann Credits. So, das ist so der normale Arbeitstag von einem Zöllner. Zollarbeit. Film ist eigentlich, oh, wir haben überlegt, was für eine Serie wir machen könnten. Das ist doch eine Zöllner-Serie machen. Fände ich gar nicht so schlecht, vor allem da niemand weiss, was die machen, können wir alles behaupten. Alles behaupten, ja. Du kannst behaupten, dass die dann irgendwie so Verbrechen aufklären oder dann sich so unten an so ein Flugzeug dranhängen, falls jemand seine Schlange vergessen hat, und dann schmeissen die noch so ins Cockpit und dann macht der Pilot so ... Und dann ...
Der Zöllnergruss.
Zöllner.
Ja, vielleicht haben wir das beste Leben der Welt.
Ja, Zöllner ...
Und jemand weiss es.
Ich glaube, es ist ein geiler Job. Gibt es irgendeinen Film, in dem es um Zoll geht? Gar keinen.
Wir fragen mal das Publikum.
Zollfilme.
Ey, falls junge Filmmacher da draußen sind, der österreichische Film boomt ja gerade, habe ich gehört.
Ja. Und deswegen ... Die österreichische Kunst ja. Ja. toll, all die Leute mit den Hüten auf und so.
Ein Bilderbuch ist toll, haben wir nicht in Deutschland.
Jan Hohen haben wir nicht in Deutschland.
Versuchst du dich gerade beim österreichischen Publikum blieb zuumachen, dass zu 80 % aus Deutschen bestehen, die hergerast sind? Das stimmt auch. Wie viele von euch sind deutsch? Okay, schwierige Frage. Oh wow! Ich dachte gerade, die Frage funktioniert nicht, weil die Leute nicht wissen, wie sie reagieren sollen. Soll ich aufzeigen, soll ich klatschen, sag mir, was ich machen soll. Wer deutsch ist, klatscht mal kurz bitte. Aber auch ein enthusiastischer Klatscher. Ist ein Heimspiel. Man weiß es nicht genau. Wir wissen jetzt aber auch nicht, wie die Gesamtmenge klingt. Wir haben keine Referenz. Naja, naja, naja. Wien. Ja, das war Österreich, das war Wien. Schön, dass Sie da sind. End credits. Ich bin tatsächlich gestern durch Wien gelaufen und ich habe einen grossen Fehler gemacht. Und ich hatte Hunger und ich glaube, man sollte nie hungrig unterwegs sein, gerade nicht durch Wien. Das ist das Schlimmste. Es funktioniert einfach nicht. Und ich bin durch die Strasse gelaufen, sehr fröhlich und ich kann es... Lauf doch mal fröhlich. Wie lasst du fröhlich? Es war so ein... naja, man läuft, man zeigt ja die Emotionen nicht, es war ja so ein ... Ja, das stimmt aber, man zeigt ... Aber es war so nach vorne ... Dieses Laufen, als würde man versuchen, nicht umzufallen. Ja, ja, ja, und die Arme hinten, die Harme zur Stabilisierung. Wenn man nach rechts geht, auch die Arme so leicht, sonst auch aerodynamisch irgendwas ändern würde. Ja, man kann schneller laufen kann schneller laufen, wenn man so läuft. Wie Animefiguren. Das habe ich tatsächlich früher auf dem Fahrrad versucht. Da bin ich freihändig gefahren und habe die Hände so ausgebreitet zum deutschen Gruß und habe versucht. Das wäre der bescheuertste deutsche Gruß. Einfach dem Typen rechts in die Fresse hauen. Funktioniert überhaupt nicht. haben lange auch andere Grüße probiert, einfach so. Aber das hat alles nicht funktioniert. Ich glaube, einfach kam es ab irgendwann. Es ist einfach zu albern, es funktioniert nicht. Und ich habe wirklich gedacht, dass ich irgendwann abheben könnte. Dass ich abheben könnte, wenn ich nur meine Tragflächen so ausbreite, und schnell genug fahre. Völliger Bullshit, du musst die so leicht drehen, dann klappt es. Ja, das stimmt. Weil dann hast du Auftrieb. Das war das einzige Problem. Ja, das machen alle falsch. Das ist lächerlich. Und ich habe tatsächlich, ich habe tatsächlich, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die Kinderfotos von mir gesehen habt, den Leak oder nicht, also ich war sag ich mal ein ... Die du geleakt hast. Ich würde meine eigene Nackt, bin ich Nacktfotos hätte, würde ich sie selber leaken. Ja, im Grunde ist jeder Post ein LeLeak eigentlich, das stimmt. Hast du nacktfotos von mir? Nein. Nee, ich auch nicht. Aber ich glaube, selbst wenn ich welche hätte, würde ich die nicht leaken. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist unser Act. Ich dachte aber tatsächlich, mein Traum war immer, alleine fl. So, wirklich alleine, nicht so dieses Flugzeugquatsch, sondern ich wollte immer einen Hubschrauber haben, den man wie ein Fahrrad fahren kann. So, und du hast halt so ein Fahrrad und dann habe ich mir immer gedacht, ich baue mein Fahrrad um, baue die Räder ab, baue da so einen Rotor oben drauf und kann fliegen und habe das dann versucht. Und ich war, sage ich mal, ein recht, naja, was ist das Wort? Naiv, dummer, fettes Kind. Wart fettes kind und ich habe tatsächlich meine Physiklehrer gefragt ist es möglich dass ein Mensch mit seiner reinen Körperkraft so viel Energie erzeugt dass er wenn er genug tritt den Rotor so stark anwirbelt du genau und dann geht das und er meinte nur … und er hat so kurz im Kopf nachgerechnet … Ah, du nicht. Was? Es war ein lustiger Typ, ich weiss nicht, ob es funktioniert hat, der war auch strange. Kurzer Exkurs zu meinem Physiklehrer, der hatte eine geheime Zutat, der wollte immer von uns wissen, was wir essen. Der hat uns immer gefragt so, was esst ihr heute? Und wir hatten uns mal so, äh, keine Ahnung. War das jetzt aufgeschrieben dann, als würde er so eine Liste führen? Ich weiß es auch nicht genau, keine Ahnung, vielleicht war das so seine Art, mit uns Schülern zu connecten, einfach so. Man würde jetzt euren Bauch aufschneiden, was würde man darin für finden, was willst du für Informationen daraus ziehen? Ich glaube, der wollte eigentlich Koch werden, glaube ich. Aber dann irgendwie, wie das Leben manchmal kommt, man wacht eines Morgens auf und unterrichtet in der 11. Klasse in Physik und denkt sich, wo ist mein Leben hin? Man muss im Tagebuch nochmal hinblättern und merkt, alle Seiten ausgerissen. Aber das ist das Bescheueste der Welt, weil Kinder essen Matschbrötchen. Ja, das war schon so Oberstufe. Da haben sie alle geschämt. Ich habe so einen Metzger, so ein Brötchen, dann drei Twix, fünf Packungen Mentos einfach so weggeballert. Ich hatte nur 45 Cent in der Tasche und habe geguckt, was ich davon kriege und habe dann Krautsalat gegessen, weil ich nichts essen kann. Aber der hat immer gefragt, was wir noch essen werden und dann hat er uns immer so Rezepttipps gegeben. Und er hat uns immer den exakt selben Tipp gegeben und er hat immer gesagt, und er hat zum Beispiel hat dann irgendwie keine Ahnung gesagt, ja, ich mache Rührei und dann hat er gesagt, na Rührei, das Geheimnis für gutes Rührei ist ja ein Schuss Mineralwasser und dann wirklich das nächste Mal hat jemand gesagt, was isst du heute, ich habe geantwortet Pfannkuchen und er meinte, ja, ja, Pfann. Ja, ja, ja. Und dann wirklich das nächste Mal hat jemand gesagt, was isst du heute?
Ich habe geantwortet Pfannkuchen.
Und er meinte, ja, ja, Pfannkuchen, ja, ja.
Das Geheimnis für einen perfekten Pfannkuchen.
Ein Schuss Mineralwasser.
Und ohne Scheiss, ich kann mir bei beiden Gerichten gut vorstellen, dass Mineralwasser
ein bisschen besser macht.
Ja, total, total.
Und irgendwann so, was isst du heute?
Und so die hippen Mädels aus der ersten Reihe so, wir essen heute Sushi.
Und er so, Sushi fit. Ganz kurz und ist noch nicht weggefahren.
Geheimnis, ja, ist dann auf so diesen Experiment-Rollwagen dann gesprungen.
Aufs Physik-Jetpack, wuhuhuhuhuhu.
Darkslide gemacht und schön aus dem Raum geslidet. Aber es war merkwürdig, er hat immer gesagt, ähm, Mineralwasser.
Mineralwasser, das war immer sein Tipp für alles. Vielleicht hat er Mineralwasser erfunden oder so. Gott. Keine Ahnung. Der Hauke hat ein ungesundes Geräusch gemacht, als ob er gleich zusammenbricht. Jetzt habe ich ein bisschen Lust. Aber er war ja auch lustig, auf eine Art. Also, vielleicht ist es nicht so schlimm. Ich hätte ein bisschen Durst bekommen von diesem Ganzen. Möchtest du dich aufmachen, die Flasche? Nö, nö, nö, nö, nö, nö, nö, nö, das kriege ich schon hin. Aufgepasst vorne. Guck mal, mach ein, zack, Druck, alles auf, alles auf. Danke, vielen Dank. Ich weiss nicht, ob es dir aufgefallen ist, der erste Applaus des Abends. Der erste Applaus des Abends dafür, dass es mit einer Wasserflasche. Danke, danke. Es ist noch Luft nach oben. Danke. Ich war aber gleich woanders. Ich bin nochmal zur Veranstaltung. Nee, nee, ich war zur Veranstaltung, ich bin fröhlich durch die Strassen gegangen und schaue mich um und habe Hunger. Und dann gucke ich so nach rechts von mir und manchmal, ja, wie erklärt man das, es war, ich sag mal so eine Bäckerei, die hatte Bäckerei, Theke, Leute und gegenüber der Theke war die komplette Wand verspiegelt. Komplette Wand verspiegelt. Super strange. Die komplette Wand war … Geheimnis für eine gute Bäckerei. Hintere Wand komplett verspiegelt. Kein Problem. Und das heisst sozusagen, der Bäckereifachverkäufer steht den ganzen Tag in seinem Bäckereifachverkäuferanzug und verkauft Backwaren, während er sich selbst sieht, die ganze Zeit. Und ich laufe vorbei und durch ein wirklich ein bizarres optisches Phänomen wirkte durch die Spiegelung, und das ist wirklich kein Witz, wirkte es durch die Spiegelung und die Reflexion in der Scheibe so, also hat sich das sozusagen in den nächsten Laden gespiegelt. Ich habe noch keine Ahnung, wo diese Story hingeht. Kein Witz, ich habe wirklich den Laden in den nächsten Laden gespiegelt gesehen. Das waren so zwei Läden, die sich so eine Reihe Schaufenster geteilt haben, sodass die Reflexion, wenn man so guckt, es so aussah, als wäre der nächste Laden, die Bäckerei, es ist wirklich wahr. Und ich dachte, oh geil, eine Bäckerei, in dem nächsten, und es war wirklich so, und ich so, oh geil, gehe ich rein, mache die Tür auf und stehe in dem Fotoladen. Oh Gott! Und der Typ in der Theke so, sie wollen wir die Bäckerei, oder? Was sitzt ständig? Er hat auch so ein paar Brezeln dabei. Ja, ich habe mittlerweile die meisten Leute, wenige Leute wollen Fotoapparate kaufen, die meisten wollen Backwaren. Und ich habe wirklich kurz an meinem Verstand gezweifelt, weil ich wirklich dachte, es ist so dumm kann kein Mensch sein. Aber wie clever von diesem Laden. Ja, aber ich weiss es nicht, ob das so clever war. Ich wollte in die Staatsoper und jetzt plötzlich bin ich im Fotoladen. Und du stehst und ich bin wirklich, also ihr erinnert euch an den Gang, ne, erinnert euch an den Gang, voller Enthusiasmus, fliege ich ab in diesen Laden und stehe da und jemand guckt mich an und ich stehe in diesem Fotoladen und denke mir, du hast, du bist mit zu viel Enthusiasmus hier reingegangen, als dass du jetzt einfach sagen kannst, ne, aber wieder gehen gehst. Also rückwärts wieder raus. Nichts, nee, wirklich. Kann man nicht machen. Es geht nicht. Wahnsinn. Man kann nichts sagen, was diese Situation erklären. Man kann wirklich nur denken, ich habe ungefähr das IQ von einem dummen Huhn, das nicht checkt, dass Dinge, die reflektiert sind, nicht da sind, wo man denkt, dass sie sind.
Und du stehst da und denkst einfach, das ist ein schöner Bilderrahmen, guck mir den mal an und dann guckt man so alibi-mässig das so an.
Haben Sie diese Canon-Unfunde?
Tausend, nee, schade.
Und es ist einfach so, du gehst in diesen Laden und du schaust den Fotomann an und du weisst, wir haben beide ein Problem. Wir haben beide falsche Entscheidungen und haben uns zu diesem Punkt in unserem Leben gebracht. Hey, was ist gegen Fotoläden einzubringen? Naja, ich habe nichts gegen Fotoläden. Ich meine einfach nur, dass vielleicht in einer Welt, in der jeder Mensch eine nahezu perfekte Kamera in der Hosentasche trägt, so jederzeit, vielleicht das Konzept eines Schleppladens nicht mehr... Darauf wolltest du eigentlich zu sprechen kommen. Naja, nein, ich weiss nicht, ich habe keine Ahnung, was in Fotoläaden passiert jeden Tag, die sind vielleicht super, aber, ja gut, ich meine, ihr habt ja so eine florierende Jugendkultur, die alle da mit so einer coolen Kamera haben, vielleicht ist dann der Fotoladen cool, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, ich stand einfach nur da drinnen und dachte mir, scheiße, und ich, keine Ahnung, ich will jetzt nicht allen Fotoladenbesitzern vor die Haustür betreten. Nee, nee, wir wollen ja nichts gegen Fotoladenbesitzer sein. Da bin ich sehr, sehr beschämt wiedergegangen.
Aber hast du was gesagt?
Ich habe nichts gesagt. Was soll ich denn sagen?
Die Spiegelung, dann habe ich einfach...
Ich habe die Spiegelung gesehen, ich da rein, ich habe so Hunger.
Ich glaube, manchmal ist sie...
Ich war da nur so glücklich, Langsler langgelaufen, kennen Sie das, wenn man Anime und dann Physiklehrer...
Ja, ja.
Aber das war... aber ich habe wirklich, das ist, es sind wirklich Momente, wo du, okay, der kam sauspät, wie lustig aber auch, sauspät, komm, ich klatsch doch nochmal, so er wusste, der Moment geht vorbei, einer klatscht immer zuerst, okay, du weisst genau, wer es war, ja, ja, hier, und du weisst, dass es viel zu spät war, aber er hat gesagt, der Moment ist noch nicht vorbei, ja, ja, der Moment ist noch nicht vorbei, ja, ja, der Moment ist noch nicht vorbei, ja, ja, der Moment ist noch nicht vorbei, ja, ja, der Moment ist noch nicht vorbei, ja, ja, der Moment ist noch nicht vorbei, ja, ja, der Moment ist noch nicht vorbei, ja, ja, der Moment ist noch nicht vorbei, ja, ja, der Moment ist noch nicht vorbei, ja, ja, ja, der Moment ist noch nicht vorbei, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja wusste, der Moment geht vorbei. Einer klatscht immer zuerst, okay, du weisst genau, wer es war. Und du weisst, dass es viel zu spät war, aber er hat gesagt, der Moment ist noch nicht vorbei. Ja, ja, den Deutschen noch mal eins reinrücken. Aber es ist wirklich, ich bin ja auch der grösste Depp der Welt, weil ich habe ja, ich denke ja, ich kenne mich ein bisschen mit Wien aus, tue ich nicht, überhaupt gar nicht. Wer kennt sich schon mit Wien aus, so eine vielseitige, schöne Tollschat. Ja, ja, ja. Und deswegen war ich mal hier mit einem Freund von von mir und habe mir erzählt, ja pass auf, in Wien gibt es ja so ein paar Slangbegriffe und so. Ich erkläre dir jetzt mal ein paar. Und zwar, Österreicher sind nicht so gut zu sprechen auf Deutsche und die Österreicher nennen die Deutschen auch nicht Deutsche, sondern Tschuschen. Und freund von mir drehte sich zu mir um und sagte nee tun sie nicht und ich so ja wahrscheinlich hast du recht tun sie wahrscheinlich ich habe einfach wenn du was du das verfassungsgericht akka sind vierzig jährige schläft genau? Ich meine, Tschuschen ist, glaube ich, abfällig für Ausländer oder für Türken oder Ausländer generell. Und es ist einfach so, du erklärst jemandem etwas, das die Person besser weiss als du. Das ist das Unangenehmste der Welt. Und du erklärst es vollkommen falsch. Und ich glaube, ich habe mich noch nie so dumm gefühlt in diesem Moment. Weil einfach so dieses, übrigens folgendes, was du noch nicht weisst und völlig falsch. Dieses Gebäude ist im Neoklassizismus gebaut, nein, das ist der Kölner Dom, der weiss, wie es fucking gotik ist. Ah ja, also ich bin nicht so klar, ich halte mich einfach raus aus dem Band. Tschuschen? Ja. Das ist aber auch schwierig auszusprechen. Ja. Das ist irgendwie so Sch. Vielleicht ist das die Idee dahinter, ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig. Du meinst, dass der Sound direkt mitgedacht wurde, dieses negative Sch. Sagt man denn Sch? Wenn man so ein Tier weggehen soll, beim Zoll, sagt man es wahrscheinlich häufig. Wenn die Skorpione mal wieder reinkommen wollen und kurz fragen, habt ihr irgendwo ein Wasser? Du glaubst, da gibt es dann extra so ein Seminar, wo man dann ausgebildet wird, wie das richtige Sch. Richtig als Skorpionumgang. Oh, wir haben eine Wortmeldung dankeschön vielen dank vielen dank wir haben ein vielen dank auch wir haben einen bananentee bekommen wir haben okay vielen dank ein bananen aber die schungte dass wir aus hygienischen gründen nicht trinken können das ist aber eine wiederverwendete nein natürlich euer tobi vielen Vielen Dank Tobi, Applaus für Tobi für diesen Bananen-Tee, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, für dieses Bananen-Tee, vielleicht Urin-Getränk, das ist, vielen Dank, wir werden das ins Labor schicken, aber es ist selber gebrauter Bananen-Tee, fast klar. Ich glaube, dein Physiklehrer hat eine gute Idee, wie man die noch ein bisschen besser machen kann. Ah, benante.
Tatsächlich überlebt Mineralwasser gekocht werden? Ist das dann immer noch? Keine Ahnung. Gar keine Ahnung. Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht. Absurd, oder? Ja, klar, überlebt ist. Nein, was? Viele verschiedene Reaktionen im Publikum. Ich glaube nicht, dass es das überlebt, weil wahrscheinlich der Kochprozess, die Blubberbläschen, das habe ich mal in so einer wissenschaftlichen Abhandlung gelesen, dass Blubberbläschen, Fussnote, Minibläschen rausgesogen werden. Kleine Blasen. Es kann sein, dass man nie zwei verschiedene Arten von Bläschen im selben Stoff haben kann. Das darf nicht, weil das würde nicht funktionieren. Die würden sie nicht verstehen. Ne, das würde auch nicht funktionieren. Die gehen immer nach oben, ne? Die immer nach oben. Wenige Blasen gehen nach unten. Hat das was mit der Schwerkraft zu tun? Also würden die woan... also... Natürlich hat das was mit der Schwerkraft zu tun. Gehen die dann auch so ein bisschen nachseitig. Weil Luft ja leichter ist als Wasser, deswegen zieht Luft nach oben.
Das war vielleicht das einzige Mal, dass ich etwas richtig erfreut habe. Ich wollte einfach Stefan mal ein Erfolgserhebnis geben.
Stefan Tietz, meine Damen und Herren, Physik!
Es ist sehr warm.
Es ist sehr warm, oder?
Aber du kannst das Zwiebelprinzip anwenden. Du kannst den Zipper machen.
Okay, danke. Hast du schon mal versucht zu strippen? Ja. Man hat ja Talente, die man kennt. Man will manchmal wissen, was man noch verbrochen hat. Ja, man weiss nicht, ist es keine Ahnung. Man kennt das ja, wenn man zusammen Flaschendrehen spielt, wenn man noch jünger ist natürlich,
und dann kommt das natürlich mal vor, dann liest es natürlich nah, dann mal zieh dir sexy den Pullover aus
und man sagt, aber ich habe den ganzen Tag geschwitzt und wenn ich den jetzt überziehe, dann ziehe ich alles aus, das kann auch niemand wollen.
Und du hast, weil du sehr vorsichtig bist, extra neun Pullover für diesen Abend angezogen, weil du wusstest, dass dieses Spiel spielt.
Darunter exakt der gleiche Pullover. Das ist ja geil, das war eine geile Sitcomcom-Folge, wie einer so dick gepackt einfach abends in der Party erscheint. Zu Strip-Hoker, ja. Alles, die Hose dreimal anhat. Und am Ende alle nackt und knutschen und du noch völlig eingepackt, Alva. Völlig eingepackt. Ich hab gewonnen! Unglückt! Und die Flasche hat selten auf mich gezeigt. Ha ha ha! So ein Pech. Warum redest du tiefer? Ich musste nicht rumknutschen, ha ha ha! Warum redest du tiefer, nur weil du sehr viele Jacken anhatst? Ist der Drück das nicht automatisch? Hohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohoh Ich habe tatsächlich mal versucht zu strippen, obwohl es jetzt nicht notwendig war, aber ich mir dachte, vielleicht kann ich's. Aber in welchem Kontext denn?
Alleine, Samstag, Samstag, 22.30 Uhr.
Dance like nobody's watching.
Nee, man weiss ja nicht, wenn ich jetzt ein super krasses Talent darin habe, stripptees zu tanzen, dann kann ich das einsetzen in verschiedenen Situationen.
Du willst möglichst viele Karten auf.
In welchen Situationen willst du das einsetzen?
Nein, Stefan, so funktioniert das Leben nicht. Du musst möglichst viele Karten auf der Hand haben, dann kannst du im Leben gewinnen. Wofür du die Karten brauchst, erst mal egal. Ich habe nicht mal eine Karte auf der Hand. Ja, das ist das Problem. Du hast immer nur die Verpackungskarte oben. Nee, dafür habe ich so Rohstoffe, ich spiele ein ganz anderes Spiel. Ich spiele die ganze Zeit, irgendwer hat noch Holz und alle so, nein, ich habe gute gute Karten aufhand. Nein, wir spielen Risiko, Stefan. Und am Ende, nee, ich glaube, du musst halt immer mal wieder, ich mache jetzt eine Metapher auf, Freunde, du musst, manchmal im Leben muss man eine neue Karte ziehen. Okay. Ist es ein Bube, ist es was anderes, kenne ich mich nicht mit Karten aus, ja, und man weiss ja nicht, was es ist, wenn man nicht zieht. Und du musst ziehen. Manchmal muss man einfach ziehen, um zu sehen, oh, schlechte Karte auf dem Friedhof. Okay, und das Ausprobieren meinst du? Auf dem Friedhof? Gute Karte nehme ich auf die Hand. Und also dieses Kann-ich-Striptease-Tanzen ist eine Karte-Ziehen. Und du denkst dir, vielleicht ist eine gute Karte, vielleicht ist die Parkstrasse, man weiss es nicht genau. Und du ziehst die Karte und ich sag mal so, es war nicht die Parkstrasse. Es war nicht die Parkstrasse, ich bin immer an den Schuhen gescheitert. Und dann denkt man sich so, in welchen Situationen stript man denn, hat man da Schuhe an oder ist es dann an einem anderen Punkt? Ich glaube auch Magic Mike. Ja, die ist auch immer gesetzt. Ja, ja, ja, ja. You can leave your head on din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din din dininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininininin Das ist Cheaten, das funktioniert nicht. Ich habe jetzt ein Karnevalskostüm, weil wir dachten ja, wir können fliegen aus Köln, weil wir hier in Wien sind.
Stell sich heraus, nein, nächste Woche ist Karneval, die haben es verlegt, damit wir da sind.
Und jetzt habe ich dann tatsächlich noch ein Last Chance Kostüm mir besorgen wollen.
Und ich brauchte dafür, ich habe mir so einen zusammengestellt, ich brauchte dafür so eine schwarze Hose.
Und es war schon im Warenkorb, ich war so kurz davor mit diesen Hosen, weil die, ich habe nicht gesehen, dass die am Rand diese Klettverschlüsse haben. Ach so, wundertsichtig. Ich dachte, es wäre eine schwarze, aber man kauft ja auch keine schwarzen Hosen in einem Kostümhandel, das sind ja keine, das ist ja immer, irgendein Gimmick ist ja immer drin. Und dann war es das, übrigens auch eine seltsame Seite, da konnte man die Kostüme auswählen, da konnte man so verschiedene Rubriken auswählen, im Mittelalter, 20er Jahre und die dritte Rubrik war Ahoi Brause. Und dann konnte man sich so grosse Ahoi Brause Kostüme anziehen, als so eine Schachtel Ahoi Brause. Wo ich mir dachte, wo war ich die letzten Monate, was ist jetzt passiert, das war als ich als Ahoi Brause verkleidet. Ja, das merke ich. Und die bekümmten dich alle mit Wasser, ha ha mit Wasser. Und du bist einfach nur nass und schwer und kalt. Und schmeckt nicht mehr. Und es schmeckt auch nicht so gut. Mir ist gerade aufgefallen, dass es Sinn macht, dass nach 20er Jahre Ahoi-Brause kommt, weil es mit A anfängt. Es war einfach nach dem Alphabet trotzdem seltsam, dass es eine Kategorie gibt, die Ahoi-Brause ist. Aber diese Hose, diese Klepperschlusshose ist schon ein Commitment.
Du musst schon, ich sag mal, du musst dein Leben sehr gut unter Kontrolle haben, dass du morgens weisst, ja, ich ziehe die heute an. Heute ist der Tag. Du musst sehr genau wissen, was in deinem Leben passiert, um zu sagen, Dienstag, 14. Oktober, ja, heute ist der Tag. Heute werde ich diese Hose brauchen. Es ist eine mega Ablenkung, aber zum Beispiel, weirdes Szenario, wo du gehst in einen Laden rein, wo du denkst, eine Bäckerei, aber das ist eigentlich ein Fotoladen. Und dann kannst du aber als Ablenkungsmanöver hinmachen und der Fototyp will gleich auch, was ein weirder Typ, cool. Dann rennst du raus und du musst noch mal rein, um die Hose zu holen. Ja, naja, musst du wirklich rein, um die Hose zu holen. Du hast ja noch ganz viele drunter. Du hast ja so 20 Hosen. Und dann war zack. Eigentlich schlecht. Ja. Also ich habe es nicht geschafft zu strippen. Also ich sag mal, ich habe jetzt so eine Karte, ich habe so eine Fallenkarte auf der Hand. So eine, wenn eine Situation entsteht, in der niemand Schuhe anhat, dann kannst du okay strippen. Also die Karte kann ich ziehen, die liegt auf dem Spielfeld. Am Strand könntest du zum Beispiel strippen. Ja, das stimmt. Badelatschen kann man gut wegziehen. Am Strand, während ich eine Wasserrutsche, runterrutsche, kann ich extrem gut strippen. Aber das Lied darf nur sehr kurz sein, weil du hast oft nur ein Kleidungsstück an am Strand. Ja, das stimmt schon. Es muss wirklich einfach rapide gehen. Und ich bräuchte eigentlich eine Wand komplett verspiegelt in meinem Haus, dann glaube ich, dann könnte ich auch sehen, wo meine Kleidung ist, dann komme ich da besser hin. Hast du viele Spiegel in deiner Wohnung? Tatsächlich wenig, ich habe tatsächlich keinen Spiegel, der mich komplett zeigt. Ist das denn bei Design oder wirklich einfach nur so passiert? Ne, ist das einfach für Vernachlässigung irgendwie, das ist so, hab ich, brauche ich nie so. Und letztens wollte ich mal meine Beine sehen, dann habe ich mir so, was geht bei euch so? Mal wieder, nach guten Jahren mal wieder meine Beine sehen. Ja, so mein Mann wacht so auf und ich denke, scheiße, ich habe noch Beine. Ich habe schöne Waden. Was war denn, ja, was ist denn aus denen geworden? Hat tatsächlich mal jemand zu mir gesagt, du hast schöne Waden. Ja? Und ich dachte mir so, was genau sind Waden nochmal, was und ich so, danke, danke schön. Ja, habe ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt, dass ich einer Frau mal ein Kompliment gemacht habe, dass sie schöne Knie hat. Und die fand das so toll, dass sie das sogar auf Facebook gepostet hat. Wirklich? Heute hat mir jemand gesagt, dass sie schöne Knie hat. Von daher ... Ich würde mich glaube ich nicht freuen. Wenn das jemand rauspickt bei mir, wäre ich ein bisschen enttäuscht. Schöne Knie. So ein bisschen so wie, du hast schöne ... Vergehen zehn Minuten beäugen. Sag nicht Brüste, sag nicht Brüste, sag nicht Brüste, sag nicht, aber alles andere ist Schuh, Schül, Schienbeine, Schöne Schienbeine, richtig schöne Schiebeine.
Du hast zwei ordentliche Schienbeine. Selten jemand mit so Schienbeinen.
Schienbeinen finde ich unglaublich ekelhaft, weil wenn du dein Schienbein fühlst.
Das ist das neutralste Körperteil, würde ich mir behaupten.
Weil hier ist ja direkt der Knochen. Was ist der Rest? Dein Schienbein finde ich unglaublich ekelhaft, weil wenn du dein Schienbein fühlst ... Das ist das neutralste Körperteil, würde ich behaupten.
Weil hier ist ja direkt der Knochen. Ja. Was ist der Rest? Hä? Normalerweise, ich stelle mir den Körper so vor, dass halt da irgendwie so Haut, fett, fett, fett, fett, fett, fett, Fett, Knochen, fett, fett, fett, fett, Haut. Sehne. Also der Knochen ist in der Mitte, ausser beim Schienbein, da ist der Knochen ganz vorne. Ja, aber ich dachte mir auch immer, ich habe lange Fussball gespielt und da zieht man diese Schienbeinschoner an, was ja wie dann wie so ein Knochen, wie so ein neues Schienbein ist.
Ja, das eigentlich ist das im See der Natur.
Das ist doppelt, das ist wie so eine Tautologie, da drunter ist ja schon ein Schienbein,
der Knochen ist ja mein Schienbeinschoner.
Ja, aber du willst ja den Knochen schützen, der Knochen ist ja alles, was du hast.
Ja, aber was macht denn Knochen aus, um mich zu schützen?
Dich festhalten, der hält dich fest. Fall dich um! Wenn der weg ist, dann bist du nur so ein Sack in einem Eimer. Ja, aber es ist doch so ein... Aber es schützt einen doch schon. Das ist wie so ein kleiner Panzer, das Schienbein. Keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, es ist auch einfach ein Knochen. Es ist einfach ein Knochen und darum ist das, was du gesagt hast. Mach mir bitte keine Komplimente zu meinen Schienbeinen. Das ist ein heikles Thema. Niemals? Das Thema. Nee, weiß ich nicht. Gibt es so Schienbeinen? Was sind die weirdesten OPs bei so Schönheitsoperationssälen? Das ist eine gute Frage eigentlich, weil es gibt immer so Prozent. Was? Schienbeinen schöner machen? Sie wollen Ihren kleinen Finger der linken Hand viermal so gross spritzen? Ja. Ich habe das in der Zeitschrift gelesen. Nee, ich habe manchmal so ein Jucken im Ohr. Ja, ja. Wenn Sie vielleicht ein bisschen länger machen können. Muss jetzt nicht viermal sein, da habe ich mir so. Ey, das ist eine super gute Frage. Da müssen wir mal mit Schönheitskriegungen anfragen. Thais! Ja, neuer Auftrag für Thais. Was ist die seltenste Anfrage bei Schönheitsoperationen? Die kriegen bestimmt auch viel so scheiss so. Nur damit ich es mal gefragt habe, bin ich schon hierher, war in der Gegend, habe ein Brötchen geholt, nur damit es mal auf dem Tisch ist, rein theoretisch, könnten Sie mir Flügel machen. Also nur jetzt mal, Sie grinsen schon, die Mundwinkel gehen schon nach oben. Ich will es einfach nur mal gefragt haben.
Nein? Gut, dann gehe ich auch wieder.
So, einfach nur nicht, dass ich jetzt die nächsten Jahre herumlaufe und hätte fliegen können.
Man weiß es nicht.
Dinge ausschliessen.
Ja.
Gucken, welche Karten man auf der Hand hat.
Ja, genau. Ich finde es nicht so schlecht.
Auch gucken, welche Karten der Schönheitschirurg auf der Hand hat.
Vielleicht hat der nur Scheisse auf der Hand.
Und du kannst sagen, hier, roll Flasch, mein Freund! Ja! Und er sagt Flügel-Dämon, hahaha. Das wäre aber echt interessant. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es funktioniert. Das hätte ja schon bestimmt mal jemand gemacht. So Marilyn Manson oder so. Hat der jetzt ja auch so Rippen rausnehmen lassen? Ja, das stimmt nicht, Stefan. Seit du 14 bist erzählt man sich das und das stimmt nicht. Das ist einfach falsch. Das ist eine Legende, die hat die Schönheitsindustrie-Lobby in die Welt gebracht, damit sie alle denken, ich frag mal nach, ich frag einfach mal nach. Da kriegen wir bestimmt auch Fragen, wie viele lebenswichtige Organe müssten sie mir entfernen, damit ich mir selber entblasen kann. Was ist nun mal so, ja Herz muss raus, okay, okay, weiter, weiter, weiter, kann ich mit leben, kann ich mit leben. Beide Lungen, ja, okay, weiter, weiter, weiter, alle sieben Nieren, okay, weiter, weiter, weiter, und dann woran geht's tun? Wir sollten über ihre sieben Nieren reden, genau. Ja, das ist echt eine interessante Frage. Ich meine, der Mensch entwickelt sich ja weiter durch Evolution, das heisst, entweder hatte er früher mehr Nieren oder weniger Nieren eigentlich, oder? Oder die Natur hat von vornherein gesagt, zwei. Einfach mal selbstbewusst, zwei. Du meinst, die Natur würfelt einfach so, zack, Zweierpärchen, wunderbar, passt. Du glaubst die Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht höher, dass es irgendwann mal so achtzehn Nieren waren? Das Thema hatten wir schon mal. Ich glaube, das ist ja auch, weil es symmetrisch sein muss. Weil die Natur auch so ein bisschen ... Ja, vier ist auch symmetrisch. Ja. Aha, du hast ja auch nicht nur zwei Finger, mein Lieber. Du hast ja fünf Finger. Aber zwei Händchen, wie man hier in Wien sagt. Händchen. Händchen? Händl, Händl, stimmt. Man kann sich so ein bisschen durchbullshiten auch in Wien. Ein bisschen verniedlichen. Niemand weiss es. Ich kenne auch nicht alle Begriffe aus der Gegend, wo ich herkomme. Wenn jemand sagt, das ist ein so und so Begriff, ja, ja, kann schon sein. Ich dachte, das schreibt man anders, aber ja. Schuschen. Ich sag das nicht einfach so. Ich kenne es nicht. Das Problem ist, man weiss ja nicht, wie schwer, wie fies, sage ich jetzt mal, solche Begriffe sind. Man kennt halt so aus seiner eigenen Sprache so, oh, das darf man nicht sagen. Aber in anderen Sprachen wirft man da mit dem N-Wort Namibias herum. Es ist nicht Namibia, sondern dann reisst du nach Namibia und haust da überall das Wort raus und alle so … Was ist das N-Wort Namibias?
Das ist keine so dumme Frage. Weisse.
Ich weiss es ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Das auch mal Thaisen, sie hat den Rest des Jahres zu tun.
Weiss ich nicht.
Wir schicken sie nach Namibia und dann kann sie sich der Maul an …
Was ist das N-Wort Namibias?
Keine Ahnung.
Und die Leute da so …
Grosse Kommunikationsprobleme auch. Was ist das K-Wort Namibias? Keine Ahnung. Große Kommunikationsprobleme auch. Was ist das K-Wort? Hm? K-Wort? Ka-Kame-Leo. Ich glaube, jeder hat irgendein Wort im Kopf, egal welchen Buchstaben man sagt. Wenn ich jetzt sag, in unserem Haus sagen wir nicht das O-Wort. Und ihr versauten Wiener, ihr versauten Wienerleine, ihr habt irgendwas im Kopf. Ofen, Leute, das ist nichts Schlimmes. Du bist da Ofen. Vielleicht sagt man das so. Ich weiss es nicht, ich weiss es nicht. Das ist so absurd, dass manche Wörter so ein bisschen anders sind. Das ist so, off. Oder wir, weiß ich nicht, sorry. Aber so Kassa. Ja, das ist schon so ein bisschen. Es ist nicht Kassa, es ist Kassa und ich sitze da immer. Das ist wie so ein wütender Teenager, der seinen Namen nicht akzeptiert. Ich heisse nicht mehr Jacqueline, ich heisse jetzt Flaming Brave. Flaming Beautiful Wave. Und die Eltern so, okay, okay. Okay, Miss Grave, was wollen wir denn zum Mittagessen? Eltern schaffen es doch immer auf so eine unkülle Ebene mehr zu heben. Na, was wollen wir denn zum Mittagessen? Rüreei? Sie wissen genau, du tätowierst dir das jetzt über deinen Arm, über beide Arme. Aber in zwei Jahren ist die Phase durch und dann heißt sie wieder Jacqueline. Und so ist sie, glaube ich, in Österreich auch. Österreich kommt irgendwann aus dieser Trotzphase wieder raus und sagt, Kassa ist … Okay, Kasse, aber sie haben es halt überall noch stehen. Kassa. Kassa. Und dann ist es so ein bisschen … ja, man springt Kasse aus eigentlich. Nee, oder? Schon Kassa. Ich glaube, die wachsen … ich glaube, Österreich ist ein Land in der Pubertät. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, wo es noch hingeht. Ich glaube, Österreich ist deutlich älter als Deutschland. Boah, weiss kein Mensch. Weiss niemand. Thesen. Sehr, sehr gewagte Themen. Nimmt was mit dieser These und zieht in die Welt damit. Aber, gute Neuigkeiten, bald ab 2020 bin ich ein Teil dieser Stadt. Oh, mo, stopp, nein, heu, heu, heu, Leute. Wie uncool. Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, langsam, langsam, langsam. Und zwar, das Sigmund-Freud-Museum schliesst bald und eröffnet 2020 erneut. Dann ist es wieder auf. So, was passiert in der Zeit? Weil die sich sagen, fuck it. Aber in dieser Zeit haben Leute kein, die haben Prophezeit, wenige Leute werden sich für Sigmund Freud in der Zeit von 2019 bis 2020 interessieren. Ja, der ist dann verdrängt sozusagen und dann kommt er wieder. Was haben die Neues herausgefunden, dass sie das noch eine Couch machen? Die wollen das barrierefrei machen, glaube ich. Das ist bis jetzt nicht barrierefrei. Die sagen, ja, ist eigentlich schon scheiße. Cool, dass sie diese lustige Frage in diese ernste Richtung schiebt. Ja, es tut mir leid. Die wollen es barrierefrei machen, okay? Es tut mir leid. Und es wird neu eröffnet und damit die das cool machen, kann man spenden. Und wenn man spendet, dann kriegt man eine Plakette. Ja, das ist so billig von denen. Das ist so. Und Leute, wenn ich eins liebe, dann eine fucking Plakette mit meinem Namen drauf. Und deswegen habe ich mich natürlich nicht lumpen lassen und habe mal schön gescrollt, was ist die günstigste Plakette, ganz nach unten gescrollt, ganz nach unten gescrollt und habe schön 50 Euro auf den Teller gelegt.
Aber ganz kurz, für 50 Euro gibt es eine Plakette im Siegwund Freud Museum.
Ja, eine sehr kleine Plakette.
Wie klein ist die Plakette?
Silberne Plakette ist eine sehr, sehr kleine Plakette.
Aber 2020 lade ich euch alle schön ein, dann könnt ihr meine Plakette anschauen.
Und dann stehe ich da, wahrscheinlich in so einer riesigen Wand mit winzigen Namen und dann irgendwo bin ich dann. Irgendwo bin ich. Und dann bin ich offiziell ein Teil dieser Stadt. Ja, und ich freue mich drauf. Toll. 2020 ist mein Jahr. Aber alle wissen so, ja, was macht der alles? Rocket Beans, dann monatliche Einnahmen beim Neomagazin und er spendet 50 Euro für die kleinste Plakette. Nicht weil er dem Museum will, sondern weil er die kleinste Pakette haben will. Ich spende ja auch für andere Sachen, so ist es nicht, ich spende ja nicht nur, nur wenn es eine Plakette gibt. Das ist völliger Unsinn. Das ist schon ein geiler Anreiz, muss man aber echt sagen. Nein, die meisten sind ja woanders. Das ist nicht so viel Geld, das ist auch für Scherze nicht viel Geld. Nee, es ist sehr günstig und die ist aus Silber und ich habe die aktuellen Silberpreise nicht im Kopf, aber vielleicht ist die Plakette teurer als 50 Euro.
Vielleicht hätten die sich weniger mit Sigmund Freud und mehr mit wie der Markt funktioniert auseinandersetzen. Mit der Markt, die die Triebswirtschaft auseinandersetzen sollen. Oh, scheiße, wir nehmen dann 50 Euro ein. Gut, die Plaketten kosten 70 Euro, weil die aus Silber sind, aber naja, dafür haben wir eine schöne Wand und die gucken sich Leute an. Ja, deswegen motiviere ich euch alle dazu auch zu spenden, damit sich das lohnt.
Und damit ihr nicht mit euren irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Crispy Bacon oder Penismeister oder irgendwie sowas, so albernen Namen dann spendet, dass meine Plakette umringt, ist von euren lauten Bullshit-Namen und ich am Ende nicht mehr Ehrenbürger dieser Stadt sein darf, okay? Lasst es. Was ich gerne für einen Scherz machen würde, ist, Sigmund Freud als Namen umzugehen. Und dann geht man an dieser Wand vorbei und dann irgendwann ... Luise, komm mal kurz. Wie kann das sein? Man kann ja da alles reinschreiben, was man will. Man kann ja auch Samuel L. Jackson reinschreiben. Und dann sagen die Leute so, nur 50 Euro von Samuel L. Jackson, also komm schon! Allein Pulp Fiction, was der da verdient hat. Das muss doch nicht sein, wenn alle böse Tweets, was fällt dir ein, Al Jackson? Papst Franziskus. Zwanny! 50 Euro von Papst Franziskus. Knickerheini. Das gibt's ja gar nicht. Mein Ziel hat 100 gespendet immerhin, ich meine, warum nicht? Ach, und das Podcast-Republikum. Ich wette, wenn diese Plakette eröffnet wird, da sind nur Bullshit-Namen, nur Nonsens-Namen einfach überall. Dank euch! Ich würde für den Scherz aber glaube ich, weil ich weiss, du machst das wirklich, das erzählst du jetzt gerade so locker lustig, du wirst wirklich so eine Plakette kaufen, und ich werde mir die teurere kaufen. Einfach die einsgrössere. Das ist auch nicht 70 Euro halt, hauptsache ich meine es ist ein bisschen grösser. Aber die bedeutet das schon mal, so großartig muss man heute werden, oder? Das ist ein Kampf, den können wir auf ewig führen. Wenn du eine grössere hast, dann hole ich mir noch eine grössere. Gut, dann kauf ich mir das fucking Museum. Wie teuer kann das schon sein? Von unten nach oben, immer abwechselnd, Flo und die will, Stefan Tietze, Flo und die will, Stefan Tietze, Flo und die will, Stefan Tietze, Flo und die will. Einfach in Caps Stefan Tietze, Florentinville, Stefan Tietze, Florentinville, Stefan Tietze, Florentinville, die ganze Warte. In Caps, Stefan-Tietze-Museum, alle so, es war mal das Sigmund-Freund-Museum, der hat mich interessiert. Stefan, wer? Fick dich Stefan, hör auf zu spenden, ich hab fast kein Geld mehr. Pass auf, wir können das Spiel auch weiterführen, okay, Will? Und alle so bei der Einweihung dann und alle so, ach Gott, tut uns leid. Wie die die Plaketten so langsam enthüllen müssen, auch immer, danke für, oh, und dann bin ich ja genervt irgendwann, so diese Feige. Danke von Pedro Phil, ha ha ha. Gott, kurze Hose, alles klar, haben wir auch schon dreimal erst gehabt. So lustig. Ich glaube, ich gehe da hin zur Einladung. Und Sigmund freut so, ich wollte die Psyche des Menschen, ich wollte die Leute näher bringen, um das zu verhindern. Ich glaube, ich will bei der Einladung, da ist es ja nur um zu sagen können, das bin ich, da bin ich, da bin ich. Und da oben steht Peens. Ach Gott. Ich glaube, das wird eine gute Zeit. Ich glaube, ich kaufe das Museum, da muss ich aber, weil ich nicht so viel Geld habe, würde ich es dann wieder Barriere ... Feindlich machen. Ja, ich weiß ... So Zacken auf dem Boden, die den Rollstuhl aufbrechen. Mir ist das Wort nicht eingefallen für Barriere, das Gegenteil von barrierefrei, barrierefeindlich. Es gibt in Ehrenfällen eine barrierefeindliche Pizzeria. Das habe ich noch nie gesehen. Völlig unbedrängt, eine ebenerdige Pizzeria hat um ihre Pizzeria eine Mauer gebaut, eine kleine, so eine kleine Mauer. Was? Und dann geht da so eine kleine Treppe hoch und wieder eine kleine Treppe runter und es macht keinen Sinn. Die ist nicht tiefer, die ist nicht höher, die ist ebenerdig und Rollstuhlfahrer müssen einfach denken, fuck you. Was ist die Geschichte von dieser Mauer? Ja, es ist einfach eine winzige Mauer, die völlig keinen Sinn macht. Da hinterliegen ganz viele Asiaten, die einfach... Ein Fall für Thais, ja. Es macht keinen Sinn, und einfach so eine kleine Treppe. Keine Rollstuhlfahrer. Nee, was würde dich eigentlich davon abhalten, morgen das Stephan-Tietze-Museum zu gründen? Du gründest das Stephan-Tietze-Museum. Vor allem finanzielle Aspekte, glaube ich. Ja, wirklich? Ego-Aspekte stehen dem nicht im Wege. Aber meinst du nicht, das würden Leute sich anschauen? Ja, zwei Leute. Die ganzen Bilder, die du gekauft hast, stellst du dann auf, dein ATS-Team mal zu sehen, ja, der kleine Grabstein für deinen Fisch, alles ist da. Ja, viele, ja, viele, dankeschön. Komm schon, du hast abgeschlossen, du bist drüber weg. Fisch ist glaube ich, sollte man schwer drüber weg sein, sonst ist man verrückt, glaube ich. Beim Fisch sollte man so nach zwei Wochen, sollte die Trauerphase, sollte er nicht mehr mit dem schwarzen Anzug zur Arbeit kommen, glaube ich. Ja, und er sollte in die Handlung gehen und sagen, den gleichen wie letzte Woche und einfach den nächsten. Nee, das ging ja nicht, weil er aus Taiwan kam. Das war das Problem. Ja, okay. Ich sag mal so, ihr wisst, was Stefan sich zu Weihnachten wünscht. Ein eigenes Museum. Ein eigenes Museum, eine Plakette. Stefan M. Tietze Museum. Da können Leute Plakette, ich würde Plakette in deinem Museum kaufen. Allein so verdienst du Geld. Du gibst Leuten die Chance, Plaketten in deinem Museum zu machen. Das finde ich ja die genialste Idee der Welt. Es gab mal eine Website, die hatte tausend Pixel. Tausend Pixel. So, und jetzt konnte, und jetzt konnte je, nee, nee, sorry, ich muss noch mal anfangen. Können wir ja Gott sei Dank schneiden. Kann wir das Hintur noch mal? Nee, es gab eine, eine Million Pixel. Wow! Gut, es wird krasser, die Steaks sind höher, okay? Also bleibt, ja, reilt euch an euren Sitzen fest, wenn ihr euch habt. Dann eine Million, eine Million Pixel. So, und jetzt konnte jeder für einen Euro einen Pixel auf dieser Website kaufen. Jetzt konnte zum Beispiel eBay sagen, gut, wir nehmen einfach jetzt 100 100 Pixel und machen daraus das Logo von Ebay mit einem Link. Dahinter ist ein Link. So, und dann kannst du drauflegen. Du kannst also quasi die Verfügbarkeit des Pixels, das immer einen Link hinterlegt, kannst du einfach frei zu seiner Verfügung auswählen. Du kannst einen Farbcode bestimmen und die Website auf die ist verlinkt. Und dann wurde, die Idee ist einfach, dass er eine Million Pixel für einen Euro verkauft. Ein Pixel ist nicht teuer, aber irgendwann wurde diese Website halt viral und Leute haben dann einfach sehr viel Geld bezahlt. Und irgendwann hat er einfach, seine Idee war einfach, ich will eine Million Euro haben. Und er hat am Ende irgendwie 20 Millionen oder sowas, weil Leute, klar, weil diese Website viral ging und dann ist der Werbefaktor einfach so gross, dass Leute angefangen haben, ganz gross einfach Amazon auf diese Website zu machen oder so Porno, oft so Porno-Seiten, YouTube-Porn und sowas. YouTube hätte ich fast gesagt, aber so weit ist es ja noch nicht. Ist schlimm geworden, aber so weit ist es noch nicht. Aber, wobei ist es auch nicht. Aber jedenfalls konnten die dann, konnten die dann halt ihren Fleck sich halt zurechtbasteln, wenn du wolltest. Krass, konntest du auch einfach auf floreinwill.com, punkt bits wahrscheinlich, ja. Ja, da können sie dann mal vorbei, Leute. Ja, konntest du dann einfach so ein Stück, also es ist schon gut für Leute, die einfach ein bisschen Geld überhatten und der Typ hat einfach am Ende sehr viel Geld für eine sehr clevere Idee. Das ist echt eine super Idee. Aber es ist eine Idee, es ist genau so auch zu machen. Einfach, wir machen einfach die eine Million Pixel-Webseite zwei. Ja, für 99 Cent pro Pixel. So funktioniert Marktwirtschaft. Aber ist das nicht sehr schwer, einen Pixel zu treffen? Wie wählt man den aus? Genau, das war die Idee, deswegen machst du halt mehr. Deswegen musst du halt zehn Euro hinblechen. Aber wie würdest du eine Million Euro bekommen wollen, wenn du jetzt sagst, eine Idee für eine Million Euro? Wie ich es bekommen wollen würde? Ja, was ist dein Plan? Was ist dein Plan? Mein Plan ist nicht Sponsoring im Podcast.
Hecklauen Koch.
Wir fangen einfach direkt mit Monsanto an und arbeiten uns dann runter.
Einfach so, und gegen Ende wird es halt bekommen.
Du, seit letzter Folge, wo Thais, unsere Schülerpraktikantin, Sponsoring sich überlegt hat, und das Geld,
mittlerweile hat sie es bekommen, ich habe es ihm Vater überwiesen, ich dachte mir schon, dass sie kein eigenes Konto hat,
und ihm Vater hat er jetzt 700 Euro bekommen von Bracenet.
Es ist ein sehr mit dem Punkt. Hättet ihr was gegen Werbung, wenn er so eine Minute Werbung, so eine Minute Werbung, die können wir wegmachen oder nicht? Die Leute sind begeistert. Die Leute, ja, bitte, gebt es uns! Na ja, mal gucken. Naja, mal gucken. Ich weiß nicht. Solche Gespräche führen wir normalerweise auch nicht vor Publikum. Naja, ich dachte, wir sind ein transparenter Podcast. Wirklich? Ja, okay, sorry. Auch solche Gespräche führt man nicht vor. Wirklich? Aber auch die Attitüde. Wirklich? Bist du für Europa? Dass Europa mehr zusammenwächst? Ich bin für Europa, aber ohne fucking Luxemburg. Auf die habe ich keinen Bock. Oh fucking Luxemburg. Ja genau, komm, lass mal einer sagen, nur weil die Kleinen sind, hallo, fickt euch. Liechtenstein. Die machen nix den ganzen Tag, die machen gar nix. Fucking Luxemburg. Hau die raus, die können ihr eigenes Ding machen. Wäre das was, so ein Musical, aber quasi wie bei Cats, nur nicht andere Katzen, sondern andere Länder? Aber welches Land singt dann am besten? Offensichtlich Amerika. Ja, okay. Und Luxemburg? Grottig, singen grottig, können nicht singen. Die Fassung muss auch so ein sehr kleiner Mensch, der singt. Ich habe gehört, die Luxemburger sind sehr, sehr klein. Winzig sind die. Wahnsinnig klein. 20 cm maximal.
Die leben eigentlich in einem riesigen Land für die, weil die so klein sind.
Ja, wie gesagt, das war immer meine Idee bei Mittelerde, weil ich dachte, die Adler sind gross, die Elefanten sind gross, die Spinnen sind sehr gross, vielleicht sind die Menschen einfach alle wahnsinnig klein und am Ende kommt so ein grosser Fuss, ist dann zu sehen, so bei der Finalschlacht, einfach drei Filme lang diese epischen Schlachten geguckt, am Ende kommt einfach ein grosser Fuss
und man denkt, ah, die waren alle wahnsinnig klein einfach.
Das Licht geht an und so, Mama, ich spiele hier.
Weirder Film, komischer Film geworden.
Irgendein Musical, wir müssen mal ein Musical schreiben. Da hätte ich richtig Bock drauf.
Danke, unser Manager in der letzten Reihe. Macht mal. Macht mal. Und man kann sich Rollen kaufen. Ich bin noch bei dieser Plakettenidee. Jedes Land... Man kann sich... Leute, also jedes... jede Rolle kostet erst mal nur einen Euro, böse Pixelidee.e, es gibt aber eine Million Rollen. So, jetzt nichts anordentlich. Und man kann sich Songs und Minuten, nein, anders, das Musical ist genau eine Million Minuten lang. Ja, gut, aber uns geht es nicht darum, das durch Eintrittsgelder reinzuholen, das Geld, sondern nur, dass Leute sich Rollen kaufen. So, jetzt kann Ebay sagen. Und jede Rolle spielt genau eine Minute lang oder was? Nee, jede Minute kostet einfach einen Euro und jetzt kann Ebay sagen, gut ich kaufe mir hundert Minuten und dann ist erst mal ein Ebay-Musical für diese hundert Minuten. Ebay, Ebay, Ebay, Ebay, Ebay, Ebay, Ebay, Ebay, Ebay, Ebay, Ebay, Ebay, Ebay, Pause. Aber eigentlich muss man dann sagen, wenn dann Ebay schon die erste Minute hat und jemand anders die erste Minute haben will, dann kann er das für zwei Euro machen. So dass du, weil niemand hört ja, oh, Dollarzeichen, oh, oh. Einer steht so auf, soll ich, in dem Moment, wo rennt man da hin, wo willst du hinrennen, Bernd? In dem Moment, wir machen eine Podcast-Folge, die ist eine Minute, eine Millionen Minuten lang. Ne, ne, ne, Sekunden, lassen Sie Sekunden sagen. Ja, Sekunden. Ich glaube, Minuten waren in falscher Richtung, kurz. Wie lange sind eine Million Sekunden? Ja, das kann man auch ausrechnen. Bestimmt noch Tage. Das kann man auch kurz ausrechnen. Eine Million Sekunden, ja, jetzt ist mit 60 der Umrechnungsfaktor. Das ist super schwierig. Das wird zu schwierig jetzt. Ich glaube, es ist aber sehr unangenehm. Und dann kann man immer doppelt so viel bieten für die erste Sekunde. Und dann ist die erste Sekunde halt wahnsinnig teuer, aber dann halt irgendwie von irgendeinem krassen Unternehmen gekauft und danach wird es immer schlecht. Und am Ende kommt dann so, ich bin Luxemburg, ab Minute sechzehunderttausend, vierhundertzwanzig, dreihundertsechzehn. Nobody cares about me. Warum mag mich niemand? Meine Hauptstadt heisst wie ich selbst. Was gibt es hier zu essen? Niemand weiss es. Alle wissen, was es in Belgien gibt. Oder Frankreich und Deutschland. Ich wär so gerne Belgien. Ich hätt so gern Klischee. Ich hätt so gern Klischee's. Und eine einzige Schreibweise. Luxemburg. Niemand weiss, ob O, U oder nur U, oder X, manche schreiben mich mit K, else what the fuck is mit euch verkehrt. Und das hat 50.000 Euro gekostet. Ich meine, das ist schon teuer. Aber ich glaube, es funktioniert. Ich glaube, es kann funktionieren. Wir haben jetzt ein paar Ideen vermengt, die Landidee, dann haben wir... Wir haben viel Geld verdient. Ich meine, wir haben viele gute Ideen gehabt. Er sagt das nicht so laut, dass wir Geld verdienen. Aber wir haben richtig gute... Ich glaube, es braucht nur diese eine Idee. Und dann haben wir alles Geld der Welt, weil die Idee so gut ist, und dann haben wir alles Geld und niemand hat mehr Geld, und dann sagen alle, ja, und Ja, dann können wir uns aber nichts kaufen, weil niemand mehr Besitztümer hat.
Denk es doch mal weiter.
Man darf nicht zu reich werden, sonst hat man ein Problem.
Das ist mein grösstes Problem.
Das ist mein riesiges Problem.
Das ist auch ein Problem.
Das Problem ist, wenn du reich bist, kennen dich Leute und jetzt von George Soros wurden
ja irgendwie so Sex...
Von dem?
Jim Soros, der Amazon-Typ. Von dem wurden jetzt so... Jeff Bezos. Soros. Der zweite Applaus des Abends. Der erste, ich fasse kurz den Abend zusammen. Der erste, weil du die Wasserflasche nicht aufbekommen hast. Der zweite Applaus, weil du nicht wusstest, Soros, Jordan Soros, Jeff Bezos. Du hast mich gewiehnt offiziell, du hast mich offiziell gewiehnt gerade. Irgend so ein reicher Typ, von dem wurden jetzt so Sexnachrichten veröffentlicht, super peinlich, will man ja nicht, dass es veröffentlicht wird, aber weil der so reich ist, interessiert es jemanden, bei uns würde es niemanden interessieren, aber der hat dann so ganz merkwürdige Sexnachrichten und man weiss nicht genau, was die bedeuten sollen, wo dann irgendwie, ich glaube, eins war so, I love you alive. Und alle so, was? Warum solltest du das erwähnen? Gab es ja schon mal Vorkommnisse in ihrem Leben? Ich meine, man kennt das ja irgendwie so in Pärchen und so Flirtsituationen, man hat recht schnell Insider, die man dann so benutzt. Und dann, ich glaube, die meisten Beziehungstextfolgen sind unverständlich für Außenstehende, weil man halt immer so seine Gags, lustig lustig, flirty flirty hat. Und ich glaube, sowas könnte das halt auch sein, dass man mal so Gags macht, ha ha ha, ich will das zu stürzen. Love your life. Und dann so, ha ha ha, ja, weil... Kettensing-Emoji, Kettensing-Emoji. Und die Leute, die diese SMS durchgucken, auch, ha ha, süss, süsses Paar. Aber man weiss einfach nicht, was es soll. Und man denkt sich, ich meine, der Typ ist Michael Soros, der Erfinder des Skateboards. Wie kommst du auf Soros, Soros? Wie hättest du das geschrieben? Nur mal so. James Sirius, okay, kennen wir einfach. Nur mal so, in dieser lustigen Traumwelt, in der wir gerade leben, wo alle Menschen Flügel haben und du durch die Strassen gehst und alles vor der Spiegel ist. Wie hättest du Soros da geschrieben? Hast du an Sauron gedacht, was war denn deine Kette an … S-O-Apostroph-R-O-U-G-H-F-F-Saurus. Sorof, so rough, man weiss es einfach nicht genau. Michael Soros klingt wie so ein langweiler Dinosaurier. Wir hatten alle Namen schon durch und dann kam Michael Soros. Michael, du kannst den Dinosaurier nicht Michael Soros nennen. Paul Soros. Das ist ja gegen Michael Saurus zu sagen. Also ein cooler Dino mit so coolen Flügeln und Kram. Michael Saurus. So Klettverschlussschuhe an, er einfach so. Michael Helm auf. Ja, aber man überlegt mittlerweile, ob nicht, weil der hat ja Amazon erfunden, das heißt, der hat wahrscheinlich so ein Amazon-Sprachsteuerungsding. Und man überlegt sich, ob das vielleicht ein Typo war, dass er irgendwie so I love you, Amy oder sowas, keine Ahnung. Aber das kann er nicht zugeben, weil er dann zugeben würde, dass es schlecht wird. Es ist ganz merkwürdig und es ist so merkwürdig, dass sich die ganze Internet-Community fragt, was der Typ erotisch mit seiner Freundin oder was auch immer schreibt. Es ist sehr merkwürdig und das will mir nicht passieren. Auch so eine Trophy-Wife, also der hat so eine für seinen Aussehen unüblich anaktive Frau. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht mal genau, wie er heisst. Vielleicht sollte man das nicht sagen. Ich weiß nicht mal, wen ich gerade bleibe, ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht mal, wie der Typ heisst, okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, wer seine Frau. Ich meine einfach nur, du einfach nur, du willst nicht so reich werden, sonst werden deine Sexnachrichten geleakt und die Leute sind verwirrt. So, das ist alles, was ich sagen wollte. Das war alles. Aber wäre das so schlimm, angenommen dein Verlauf, dein privat, dein Intimster Verlauf würde geleakt werden, wäre das so... Naja, die Frage... Die Frage... Wäre das so schlimm, oder ist es so... Die Frage ist halt, mit wem und... Bei mir wäre es meistens sehr pragmatisch einfach. Ja? Ja, wenig Smileys, wenig Gefühle, einfach sehr viel ... Ja, bei mir auch, aber viele Gags, die nicht zünden bei mir auch, so viele Anspielungen, die nicht verstanden werden und vieles ... Hä, wie meinst du das? Das sollte ein Gag sein. Sorry, aber kurze Frage an euch. Ich habe für uns als Reisegruppe eine Wien-Gruppe gegründet.
Warum soll ich eine Gruppe gründen überhaupt dafür?
Lies mal den Nachricht vor.
Na ja, erst mal, die Gruppe hieß ... Das war schon ein Scherz.
Stopp, nein, du darfst nichts sagen, sonst sind sie parteiisch.
Du liest es einfach vor und fragst dann, wie die Leute denken, dass es gemeint war.
Ja genau, aber ich habe ja vorher ... Okay, aber ich lese vorher ... Die Gruppe heisst
Wien, blaue Kappe, Emoji, Tomatendosen-Emoji, Fisch, Lampignon, Emoji, so. Dann habe ich geschrieben, hey Leute, wie warm ist es in Wien, reicht eine dünne Jacke und meint ihr, mit zwei Paar Socken komme ich hin, habe auf jeden Fall genug Bargeld mit. Förendin, bringst du deinen Bluetooth-Speaker mit? Fragezeichen, so, ich dachte mir, ich mache so eine lustige Jugendherberge. Nein, stopp, das ist schon Einordnung, das ist schon Manipulation. Jurethin will schreibt. Stopp, stopp, war das wer von euch ... Du kannst dich einordnen jetzt. Nee, ich will die Jury fragen, wer von euch hat das als Gag verstanden? Oho! Nene, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Nee, nee, nee. Aber ich hatte jetzt Klagekennzeichnis durch blaue Kappe-Emoji, Wien blaue Kappe-Emoji. Ja, aber das ist in dem Team der Gruppe. Ihr habt so offensichtlich als ruide Teamgruppe aufgemacht. Und dann kommt von Flo und die will die Antwort, ich bin schon in Wien, ich habe keinen Bluetooth-Pieger dabei. Es ist kühl, aber nicht kalt. Danke. Es ist kühl, aber nicht kalt, das ist eine gute Antwort. Es ist kühl, aber nicht kalt. Dann Sus kühl, aber nicht kalt, ist eine gute Antwort.
Es ist kühl, aber nicht kalt. Dann Susa schreibt, dünne Jacke ist für abends denk ich zu wenig, ansonsten einfach eine Pulli, zwei Pfarr Socken gehen voll klar.
Leute,
und ich dachte mir auch, alles klar, wollen wir die Tour absagen vielleicht?
Wir haben alle offensichtlich nichts mit Comedy, mein Reingeher war komplett schlecht,
Floritins Antwort, kein Humorverständnis, von uns kommt nichts, niemand von uns, wenn man diese Gruppe leakt, würde niemand davon ausgehen, dass ein Comedy-Podcast, alle würden sagen, das sind weirde Leute einfach. Ja, es stimmt, ich hatte so das Gefühl, irgendwas geht mir hier durch die Lappen, irgendwas verstehe ich hier nicht. Ich konnte es aber auch nicht auflösen mehr, weil das war dann auch irgendwie, man war schon so tief in dem Rabbit Hole gefangen. Aber allein die Frage, soll ich eine Jacke mitnehmen? Die war auch ernst gemeint, die war ernst gemeint. Ihr wisst es jetzt vielleicht nicht, aber mit Stefan unterwegs ist, es ist ein ständiges, ist zu warm, ist zu kalt, ich ziehe Jacke aus, es ist zu kalt, ich ziehe Jacke an, es ist immer noch zu warm. Nein, das stimmt alles nicht. Hin und her. Nein, aber. Man bräuchte irgendwo, man bräuchte. Sie kommen mit die Impro-Regel. Nein, aber ich bin eigentlich ganz anders. Du bist schon ein bisschen empfindlich, oder? Was Wärme angeht, geht so. Nöchtens, wenn es zu warm ist. Oder wenn es zu kalt ist. Oder wenn es ein bisschen zu kalt ist. Aber alles andere ist wärmemässig gar kein Problem. Warum gibt es nicht noch mehr? Warum gibt es nicht zu ... Man hat jetzt eine Geschmacksrichtung entdeckt. Ich schon wieder? Umargi. Ja, das ist ja schon... Naja, um jetzt... Nee, nee, nicht Umagi. Moment. Oh, man hat eine Farbe entdeckt. Leute, du kannst nicht irgendwo auf diesem Paint, mit dieser Regenbogen bei Paint... Da, da! Und die Wissenschaft und bei Bild direkt eine Schlagzeile. Scheiße, zwischen Orange und grün, geil, da sind wir nicht draufgekommen. Michael-Saurus-Farbe. Michael, hör jetzt auf, Dinge zu benennen, Alter. Gott, ey. Wie ist es Ihnen denn gelungen, diese Farbe zu finden, also diesen Jahrhunderte alles umwerfenden Fund zu tätigen? Wie haben Sie es geschafft? Na, einfach zwischen grün und beige war so ein Nübel.entlich war es so ein Krümmel auf meiner Maustaste,
da bin ich da ausgerutscht und dann war das Bild eingefärbt.
Aber seit Jahrhunderten arbeiten Menschen, Künstler, Picasso, verschiedene Menschen.
Mit Farben und sie, wie ist ihnen das gelungen?
Nehmen wir so Maustaste und dann habe ich da auf Command S gedrückt, dann war es gespeichert und dann war es Farbe.
Und wie nennen Sie Ihre Farbe?
Michael Soros II. Hat er vielleicht am meisten Geld gezahlt, damit Sie die Farbe so nennen? Ja, mich hat ein Michael Soros kontaktiert und er war bereit, erhebliche Summen zu zahlen. Aha. Für mein Musical, der hat einige Dachten nicht verstanden, glaube ich. Okay, und wie schreibt man Soros? S O Apostroph R-S-T. Dankeschön. Haben Sie noch Fragen? Nee, was ist Ihr Job genau? Ich bin Redakteurin bei RAN. Ah ne, das ist ein Sportmagazin, fuck! Was, bist du Redakteurin bei RAN? Redakteurin? Ja. Warum? Ja, ich kann doch auch eine Redakteurin sein. Ja, warum nicht, aber warum? So, das war unser Bericht vom Erfinder der neuen Farbe. Das ist eine schöne Farbe. Ist eine schöne neue Farbe. Ist das, ist unser UFO nicht eine andere Farbe? Es ist weder türkis, noch hellblau, noch cyan, es ist ein bisschen neben cyan. Ich weiss es nicht genau, keine Ahnung. Haben nicht alle einfach diese sechs Stellen, diese Codes? Alle Farben haben da einen Namen, der ist halt dann nicht geil und catchy, so wie blau. Oder FF694C zum Beispiel. Oder 000. Da haben wir sie. Auffällig buntes, nerviges Shirt. Sehr viele ratlose Gesichter. Sehr gut, so muss das sein. Aber gibt es ja nun endlich viele Farben eigentlich? Weil eine Farbe ist ja eigentlich nur eine Wellenlänge von Licht. Also jede Wellenlänge hat eine Farbe. Aber gibt es denn nun endlich viele Wellenlängen? Oder ist es dann auch so mit dieser Planck'schen, konstant der kleinen Szenen der Kekateete? Ne, irgendwann wird es dann ja kompliziert. Also irgendwann … Gut, danke. Es wird irgendwann kompliziert und egal was hier kocht, ballert Mineralwasser rein. Das war's von mir, das war Physik für heute. Ne, wenn die Wellenlänge nämlich zu schnell wird, entsteht sowas wie … oder zu langsam, ne, zu schnell. Ich lebe mich fest, zu schnell wird's UV-Licht zum Beispiel und so irgendwann wird's Strahlung, röntgenmässig Strahlung. So, wenn es zu langsam wird, unterbrech mich, wenn ich irgendwie scheisse habe. Bitte unterbrech ihn. Bitte unterbrech ihn. Und wenn es zu langsam ist, dann ist es auch scheisse. Ja, das stimmt. Unsere Augen haben sich ja eingeschossen auf so ein Farbspektrum. Ja, die können nicht anders, die können nicht loslassen. Das ist so Routine, die haben sich so eingeschossen auf ein spezielles Farbding. Kann man denn Geräusche machen, die tiefer sind als die, die man hört? Als Mensch hat man ja ein gewisses Hörspektrum, ne, und dann heisst es immer so, Krabben können tiefer werden oder so. Und die so, fuck, gib Krabben, ey. Und dann immer so ein Scheiss. Aber kann man denn einen Ton machen, den man nicht hören kann? Ja, durchaus. Ja, also ich meine... Manche Boxen können das sogar, manche Kinoboxen können das sogar machen.
Ja, aber jetzt kannst du mit deinem Mund.
War das dann eine Reaktion auf diesen weirden Funfact? Ja, ja, klar, aber mit deinem Mund.
Ja, dass eine Maschine Dinge kann, die Menschen nicht kann, habe ich schon mal gehört.
Aber kann man mal so, das hört jetzt nicht mehr.
Zehn Minuten ist das der Podcast.
Was war das für eine Veranstaltung, wo du da gestern warst? Ne, die haben auch lustige Sammelsen. Aber ich werde mal immer tiefer und irgendwann hört man es nicht mehr. Weil du keine Geräusche machst. Und jetzt ist, ne, ne, ne, mach ich immer noch, mach ich noch. Jetzt musst du noch mal anfangen, weil ich dich unterbrochen habe. Warte. Ruhe Leute, wir machen hier ein physikalisches Experiment. Warum fängst du an mit dem Digeridoo? Jetzt, als wäre das besser, als wäre dann das Geräusch perfekt, was danach kommt. Okay, Achtung! Luft!
Da war noch ein Geräusch, da war noch ein Geräusch!
Ja, Luft!
Und jetzt kann man das maschinell wieder hochdrehen, dass man es wieder hört?
Nein!
Nein, okay, gut, ich wollte nur eine Antwort!
Aber ich weiss es nicht genau.
Was ist Didgeridoo eigentlich für ein Instrument?
Ich weiss es nicht genau.
Hat da jemand mal einen geilen Song mitgespielt? Gibt es einen geilen Didgeridoo-Song?
Ich glaub nicht, ich glaub nicht. Kann man da mit einer Melodie spielen und es ist die ganze Zeit nur Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bömm, Bö Können Sie einfach aufhören, einfach aufhören. Ich weiß nicht, ich hab für das Konzert bezahlt, aber können Sie es einfach weglegen?
Können Sie es bitte einfach weglegen?
Sprechen, das ist ein Digi-Du-Konzert.
Ja, ja, ja, können Sie es einfach weg, einfach aufhören.
Wir sind noch drei Akte, wir sind noch 13 Akte.
Wir hören einfach auf, einfach weg damit.
Und ich meine, hast du diesen Typen, der diese Kinderzähne in so einem grossen Stock drin hat?
Ich hab ein noch beschisseneres Instrument. Ich meine, kannst du einfach so eine... Das nächste Mal was weniger Postmodernes. Ja, ja. Einfach so eine ganze Sinfonie schreiben, so 50 Minuten und du hast einen so einen Kinderzahnmann, der dann immer so wirklich die ganze Zeit so
die ganze Zeit einfach hinten. Das fände ich gut. Aber gibt's so, also wo wir gerade in Österreich sind, Mozart und so,
Ja, ui, ui, ui. So, er hat halt ne Geige.
Wollfall.
Aber er hat halt ne Geige.
Das war sein Unsinn Klavier.
Er konnte alles gut spielen.
Er konnte besser Klavier spielen als Geige.
Das weiß ich schon, ja, ja, ja.
So, und dann, aber jetzt gibt es ja auch in Australien wahrscheinlich so eine Art Virtuose am Didgeridoo. Ja, das stimmt, ja. So ein Crazy-Gut, wo alle die Didgeridoo spielen können, sagen, he's the best. Der Mozart das Didgeridoo. Ja, genau. Aber nur weil er dieses weird Instrument spielt, kann er die Welt nicht verändern. Das stimmt. Mozart kann die Welt verändern, weil er am Klavier ein Genie ist.
Aber der Typ, am besten wie du nicht. Warum hast du das jetzt in Anführungszeichen?
Das erste Mal, dass jemand das Wort Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart und Genie benutzt hat und Genie in Anführungszeichen gesagt hat.
Ich glaube, das Bild von Mozart ist im Wörterbuch neben dem Wort Genie.
Und du, Genie.
Und du die ganze Zeit, dieses Wörterbuch ist falsch.
Mein Tagebuch ist besser sortiert als dieses Wörterbuch, wenn das Wort Genie neben Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart steht. Nee, aber du kannst die Welt nicht verhindern mit dem Ditchery, du, das will ich nur sagen. Du, ich bin der weltbeste Stripper und ich glaube nicht, dass irgendwann mal eine Kugel nach mir benannt werden wird. Deswegen einfach, wenn er... Was? Wie die Mozartkugel. Einfach so sagt, so wie viele Kugeln, wie viele benannte Kugeln kennst du denn? Billard, Jean-Pierre Billard, Bowling, James Bowling, Dieter Bowling, wäre vielleicht besser, naja. Naja, kann man noch raus schneiden. Wäre nicht besser, ich schneide das Lachen dann raus. Das stimmt schon. Und dann so ein Lacher noch rein von euch. Hahaha, wir nehmen alle noch beim Ausgang noch Lacher von euch aus, damit ihr das nochmal schön reinschneiden. Wusstest du, dass sie bei Seinfeld zu viel gelacht haben, habe ich schon mal jemand erzählt? Ich glaube schon, ja. Die wussten, oh Gott, ja, nächster, nächster, bitte, nächstes Mal lustig sein, ich will lachen. Ja, wussten wir. Ich hätte hierärmlich Angst, weil ihr seid, also Wiener Publikum in meinem Kopf ist wahnsinnig oft. Ja, ihr seid besser ausgewählt. Bei Konzerten, bei coolen kulturellen Veranstaltungen und dann seid ihr bei uns dödeln und dann kommen so Aussagen wie, nach welcher Kugel wurde das schon mal benannt. Und dann will man, ich hätte da auch das Bedürfnis reinzurufen, so, nächster Witz, danke, weiter.
Die Wiener sind einfach sehr anspruchsvoll, die sind einfach Besseres gewohnt.
Die sind halt einfach Mozart gewohnt und diese ganzen coolen Jugendtypen und so,
und dann kann man einfach nichts dagegen machen.
Dieser Didgeridoo-Mann hat in Wien doppelt und dreifach keine Chance. Einfach so, der schafft es vielleicht, vielleicht in Münster, ja, vielleicht, wenn es so hochkommt.
Münster?
Vielleicht hat er da mal irgendwie so ein Seniorenheim, zwölf Leute kommen oder so. Die meisten sind alle taub, einfach taubes. Taube Abteilung, gibt es da so Abteilungen? Werden, jetzt vielleicht jetzt, ich will es nicht fragen, aber werden die, werden in Seniorenheimen nach Krankheit sortiert? Ja, weil ich kann mir vorstellen, wenn du taub bist, verschwisst du dich mit anderen Tauben auch gut. Das ist wie so im Kindergarten, die Marienkäfer im Kindergarten, die orangene Gruppe, so du teilst in Gruppen ein. Da wäre es doch naheliegend, die nach Behinderung oder nach Krankheiten einzuteilen. Ich würde sofort mich taub stellen, weil ich könnte mir nicht, nee, stimmt, nee, weil die machen ja auch Zeichensprache, die sind ja leise den ganzen Tag, das ist grossartig. Für mich wäre das das schönste, mit tauben Menschen zusammenzuleben, weil die immer leise sind. Und man muss manchmal gerade mal auf, wie so rumzufuchteln, ich will mich konzentrieren. Halt mal die Fresse, kannst du immer. Ich schau gerade einen Film, bitte kurz die Fresse halten, bitte. Was ist das Zeichen für Halt mal die Fresse? Das Internationale für. Das hatten wir bei meinem Zivildienst mit Kindern immer, hatten wir so einen Regler. Dann haben wir gesagt, wenn es leise werden sollte, dann haben wir so einen Regler gedreht. Und die Kinder, scheiss drauf, ist mir scheissegal. Scheiss drauf, scheiss drauf, hast du Richtung lauter gedreht oder Richtung leise? Spiegelverkehrt und wir so, pädagogik. Manchmal funktioniert es einfach nicht. Ich zähl bis drei. Gut, ich zähl bis sieben. Kann schon bis neun zählen. Ja, fick dich leer. Naja. Kann gut zählen. Richtig, richtig gut. Die haben Zahlen ausgelassen manchmal, ne? Die haben eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, acht, neun, zehn. Und ich so, oh. Was doch. Was für faul ist, du korrigieren, oder was? Ja, zehn Prozent Fehler, gut ist okay. Kommst du auch mit durch. Wer braucht denn die acht? Also sorry, wer hat denn wirklich mal die acht gebraucht? Na gut, okay, hier und da ist die acht. Die acht ist nicht so trivial. Welche Zahl würdest du am ehesten streichen? Sechs. Wenn es jetzt hiesse, eine Zahl muss raus, so dieses Boot ist zu klein, die Luft ist mit Blei gewürzt, es muss eine Zahl muss raus. Luft ist mit Blei gewürzt, wer hast du denn? Es muss einfach... Ich will das einfach mal sagen, es ist so ein Cowboy-Spruch. Wirklich? Ja, so, ey, jetzt liegt Ärger in der Luft, Johnny. Ich schiesse und dichte beruflich. Das wird Jackie überhaupt nicht gefallen. Aber alle sind so, frisst Dreck und frisst meine Blei. Und da kommt er mit, die Luft ist mit Blei gewürzt und alle anderen Cowboys so, Alter, einfach direkt. Diese Stadt ist zu gross für uns, klein für uns meine ich. Scheiße, ich komme nochmal rein. Diese Stadt ist zu gross. Ich komme nochmal rein, scheiße. Ich will einfach, ich will einmal in meinem Leben in so eine Situation kommen, wo sie eine Schlägerei in der Luft liegt und man sich dann noch so cooles spricht. Deswegen hatte ich so viel Hoffnung auf die Rollerbande. Meine Faust ist mit einem Magneten gesegnet und dessen anderer Pol in deinem Gesicht ist. Ja, meine Faust hat nach einer Verabredung mit deinem Wangenknochen, du Lappen, du. Du Lappen, du. Meine Faust hat dein Wangenknochen nach rechts geswiped bei Tinder. Und alle so, es wird immer komplizierter. Meine Faust ist die Biene, die von deinem Nektar kosten will. Also dein Gesicht ist die Luft. Und dann werden diese Verläufe geliebt und dann ist alles verloren. Dann ist so, was meint der damit? Wie weird ist das denn? Ey, gut, dass es im Wilden Westen keinapp gab, die einfach so, was soll das heilen? Die Luft ist mit Blei gehörst. Irgendwann einfach so, Leute, können wir uns einfach erschießen, sorry, ich hab nicht die Zeit, jeden Tag mit dem Scheiß auszudenken. Ich hab meine Knarre mitgebracht, nicht mein Poetry Slam Buch, sorry. Ich dachte, wir töten uns, nicht mit Worten. Ich wär so bereit, ey, ohne Witz, wenn irgendjemand meine Pistole auf mich richtet, ich hätt so geile Sprüche.
Es ist einfach so gut.
Wo coole Sprüche draufstehen. Nicht weg, nicht weg lang. Werd auf. Das wird Jackie überhaupt nicht gefallen. Du sitzt auf seinem Platz, Compadre. Compadre? Was? Amigo. Und auf seinem Elektro-Roll. Und du, hey, ich hab noch zehn coole Sprüche, halb da.
Es klingt einfach super uncool.
Du kannst nicht so bedrohlich um deinen Opfer rumkreisen mit Elektro- Wuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuh Deswegen die Taucherbrille, um es cooler zu machen. Das stimmt, so als Trademark. Wir sind die Taucherbande.
Warum gibt es nicht so Sonnentaucherbrillen eigentlich, die so ein bisschen dunkler sind, damit es cooler ist?
Das war es von uns, macht's gut, ciao!
Was man bräuchte, wäre eine Brille fürs ganze Gesicht.
Einfach wirklich so, wie so Fechter haben doch hier so Masken.
Woo, Fechter!
Wo ich immer nicht wusste, ob...
Die Stadtfechter, gibt es in Deutschland.
Nein, nein, nein, die haben hier so ganz Kopf, wie so ein Donut, nicht Donut, aber wie so, wie so, ich weiss nicht, ob ihr Power Ranger die X-Zero-Generation gibt, aber da hatten die so Symbole als Visiere. Der eine hat ein Kreuz, der andere, die eine, das eine Mädchen hat ein Herz und eine hat auch so einen Kreis einfach so. Der eine hat die Sinuskurve, der gesagt hat, ich kann gar nicht sehen, Leute. Keine Ahnung, was passiert. Guck ich den Gegner an? Nein. Es war eine weirde Staffel. Ich meine, Power Rangers sind immer ein Thema für sich, aber das war so eine strange Staffel. Aber da gab es die, ich glaube die Gelbe, die Gelbe, die Asiatin war. Ja. Fuck einfach, scheiss drauf. Der Schwarze war schwarz. Und der Rote war Indianer halt, das war wirklich einfach fucking.
Und der Blaue in Schlumpf, Leute, so geht das nicht weiter.
Und die hatte auch so einen Kreis im Gesicht als Augen.
Ich glaube, es würde funktionieren, wenn du einfach statt einer Brille einfach so eine grosse Glasscheibe direkt vor deinem Gesicht hast.
UV-Strahlung geschützt.
Idee, Windschutzscheiben im Auto für alte Menschen, einfach Brille vergessen, direkt so eine Gleitsicht Windschutzscheibe. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,, so schwacken, ja. Wuhu! Kannst du also... Yee-haw! Ja, Formel-1-Autos haben, wenn es regnet bei denen, haben die nicht kleine Scheibenwischer in ihren Helm, sondern die haben verschiedene Folien, die die immer abziehen. Ja. Was? Wenn eine nass ist, dann ziehen die die ab? Ja, die haben kleine Folien, die sie abziehen. Die haben ganz viele kleine Folien. Das ist richtig, das ist wahr. Und ich bin der Einzige weiss. Weil dieses Raunen, das kenne ich. Leute wissen das. Das ist Bullshit. Und dann musst du alle zwei Sekunden eine Folie abziehen. Ja, die haben sehr viele Folien. Sehr viele Folien. Ja, deswegen ist es ja so hilarious. Ach so, das musst du mir irgendwie zeigen, Stefan. Du musst es abziehen. Verdammt, sorry, es ist ein bisschen laut geworden. Ich glaube, raus. Aber das ist wirklich lustig. Warum stecken wir so viel Energie in Formel 1 und fast keine Energie in Rentner? Die beste Strategie wäre nämlich einfach auf Krupp. Okay. Die beste Strategie wäre, das eigentlich anzuwenden, wenn du halt einen kurzsichtigen Formel-1-Fahrer hast., dass er das abmacht, dann muss er das gezielt hinter sich werfen, so Mario-Kart-mässig, und dann kriegt der andere Fahrer das hinter ihm drauf, dann steht da so Fuck-you-Loser auch drin und dann Unfall tot. Aber das ist dann egal, du hast die Meisterschaft gewonnen. Ja, das stimmt. Haben die nicht eh Navi auch eigentlich? Die haben Navi. Ja, die rechts abbiegen. Autopilot-mässig dann? Ja, ja, haben die schon. Egal. Schon auch. Ich hab das nicht. Gibt's eigentlich auch so Wettrennen auf Gleisen oder so? Ne, also Zug-Wettrennen gibt's nicht. Warum haben Züge ein Lenkrad? Haben sie ein Lenkrad? Ja, wirklich? Ja, Joystick. Keine Ahnung. Früher hatten sie ein Lenkrad. Hier ist übrigens ein Das ist ein altes Lokomotiviv. Hier wurden Lokomotiven gebaut, kein Scheiss. Da wo du sitzt war früher ein Haufen Kohle. Und jetzt sitzt du da. Wie krass ist das denn? Da wo du sitzt war früher eine Kantine, eine stocklangweilige Kantine, wie in jedem anderen Werk auch. Aber glaubst du, hier gibt es noch so Lokomotivgeister oder so, die hier so vergessenas. Nee, der Lokomotivführer. Thomas, oh, das ist wirklich saugruseliges Mondgesicht. Ja, Thomas die Lokomotive. Und der schwarze Mann für Kontrolleur. Wo du dann einfach mal sagst, okay, wir pitchen den, das ist eine Kindersendung, Züge, die sprechen können.
Und dann sagt der Executive Producer so, okay Züge, das heißt, die können nicht überall hin, wo sie hinwollen,
sondern sie können sich vorwärts und rückwärts bewegen, auf den Gleisen.
Lass uns einen Film über Lukas Lokomotive schreiben, wo er entdeckt...
Lass ihn uns retten! Ja, er ist halt nicht auf den Gleisen. Er steht halt leicht neben den es gibt nur wenige Weichen in meinem Leben. Ja, ja, ja. Und dann kann ich immer nur und oft fahr ich im Kreis, weil mein Weg vorherbestimmt ist. Ja, ein Unzug ist das. Ich bin eine Lokomotiv. Abspann jetzt? Abspann jetzt? Es ist, ich fahr tatsächlich und ich muss zugeben, zu meiner Schande und, und ich habe noch nie eine einzige Folge davon gesehen, und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, wie so eine Folge aussieht, weil du kannst ja das nicht machen, weil alle anderen Figuren müssen ja dann auf Gleisen sein, und dann fährt man dem Verbrecherzug hinterher. Warum Verbrecher? Du brauchst ja irgendeine Story, also irgendwas muss ja passieren als Plot irgendwie, keine Ahnung, der hat die Kohle geklaut. Der Mädchenzug freut sich, dass der Jungszug da ist. Ja, aber dann stehen die halt leider nicht mit den Gesichtern zueinander, sondern der Mädchenzug steht so und dann so, okay, kannst du kurz in die Wendestation fahren, damit wir uns unterhalten können? Die ganze Zeit dahinter teilen, es ist massiv. Das war so, hey, ich hab dich noch nie von vorne gesehen. Unglaublich schwierig einfach. Und dann immer dieses Wenden so, oh nein, der läuft in die andere Richtung.
Ja genau. Es ist, wirklich, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, ich muss mir glaube ich mal eine Folge angucken, weil ich kann mir beim besten Willen nicht vorstellen, was da plotmässig passieren soll. Wirklich nichts. Das ist wie wenn du so eine Serie machst über, keine Ahnung, Sandy die Seilbahn.
Und dann ist es einfach so, Sandy die Seilbahn!
Ja, und ihre Abenteuer, Sandy, Sandy. Was erlebt sie heute? Sie fährt einfach auf dem Seil. Sandy, Sandy, das war Sandy die Eisbahn. Staffel zwei, sie fährt 20 Minuten später wieder runter. Sandy, Sandy, Seilbahn. Das ist Sandy die Seilbahn. Oh, er steckt ein dicker Mann ein, Sandy, Sandy, die Seilbahn. Oh, jemand will das Seil durchschneiden. Sandy Sandy die Seilbahn. Oh, der hat es geschafft und Sandy ist gestorben. Ich meine, du hast keine Chance für Plots. Schreibt mal mehr als eine Staffel für eine fucking Seilbahn. Fucking Sandy die Seilbahn. Oder Aaron der Aufzug. Einfach, es wird immer, Leute, es funktioniert einfach nicht mehr. Oh, nicht. Es hält mir schwer, das sagen zu müssen, aber das war es für heute. Das war leider der Abend. Ich freue mich sehr, dass ihr alle gekommen seid. Ja, vielen, vielen Dank fürs Kommen. Ich hoffe, es war auch für die Stehenden in Ordnung. Vielen Dank, dass ihr das ausgeheilt habt. Es tut mir nicht leid, aber bis wir die wieder vorkommen. Vielen Dank fürs Durchhalten und fürs Dasein. Vielen Dank, ihr könnt jetzt noch natürlich an unseren Merch-Stand, da werden wir auch gleich auftauchen.
Und da könnt ihr uns weitere tolle Serienideen pitchen, ich freue mich auf alles.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr da seid, es war uns eine Ehre gesetzt.
Es war uns eine Ehre, vielen, vielen Dank Wien.
Vielen Dank Wien, fantastisch, vielen Dank ist es kommen, vielen Dank ist es kommen.
Mit Stefan Tietze und Florentin Will.
Dankeschön, Dankeschön.
Danke Wien.